[Musique]
françois installant week-end alors ça
s'est bien passé
pourquoi n'était pas là le mec adacore
[Musique]
magnéto serge
bonjour bon bah
bienvenue sur le plateau de tout le
monde en parle l'émission qui tient tête
au programme américain avec nous ce soir
roland dumas l'ont bâti
les voleurs
on va
antidote
et à droite
et
[Applaudissements]
juge du patinage de sauver 6
emma de gauche
button
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nation rentrée n'est plus notre fameux
blind test consacré ce soir au pape
c'est normal c'est la journée de la
femme
[Musique]
avant de recevoir mon premier invité je
vous propose de regarder ensemble les
meilleurs moments de l'émission
précédente
ça s'appelle tout le monde en a parlé et
s'est préparé par monsieur jean yves
noël neto serge esprit canal
oui situé sur ce plateau manifeste toi
oui vous êtes incroyablement sexy oui
comment arrivez-vous à résister aux
sollicitations féminine mais je ne
résiste pas je n'aime pas je ne peux
absolument pas tout paris bruisse de vos
exploits
on dit que vous êtes un super coup c'est
vrai c'est vrai nous a pas empêché de
devenir un très grand acteur mais vous
avez été défigurée à cette époque des
figures et non voudrait les connais des
figures et je suis pas plus et figuré
que je le suis maintenant je vous
appelez ça des figures et cassante est à
gauche qu'est-ce que ça devait être
avant je me dis pas non mais c'est un
peu comme vous chirac à il ya un an ils
veulent en prison pratiquement 1
et puis maintenant on veut lui donner le
prix nobel de la paix mais si j'avais vu
un retournement pareil et sur une liste
de 1 million ou deux millions de
personnes comme les dj la villa de ses
chances et tout d'un coup ils ont adhéré
ils sont venus ils ont voté c'était
vraiment ça c'était un moment très c'est
vrai qu'à l'époque
c'est vrai qu'à l'époque chevènement
était à 15 % quand vous êtes venus non
mais c'est leur mérite une baffe
j'attends prendrait regarder si vous
avez appliqué tu vas bien beau françois
bien ou là ça y est on est on sait ça
parlait alors qu'il a dû leur revente
depuis longtemps de son autobus colza
jamais compris ce truc
ouais c'est une des meilleures idées que
j'ai jamais eu
c'est dire la qualité des autres et donc
les chauffeurs de taxi nous aiment ils
nous écoutent tout le temps et quand on
vous montez dans un chauffeur de 3,6 la
seconde affaire c'est pas moi toute ma
démission je suis à l'agitateur un
provocateur
voici réseau se présentait déjà j'adore
sur des oeufs
immédiat c'est logique non c'est un
saint mariens comment vous savez qui
c'est les enfants
c'est inédit voilà la culture moderne
salue jean pascal de l'astarac paru non
mais il ya certains grands auteurs à qui
était desquels je suis pas ceux là on
voit bien là on va bien
rations et a dit quel connard c'est
philippe bouvard c'est un ami à vous non
et on raconte je sais pas si c'est vrai
que vous allez partir en irak pour
devenir boucliers humains à bagdad
nan sérieux c'est vrai ça fait rire
toute l'histoire de la guerre en irak
non tu aurais vu avec madelin ou bien
que ça me faisait pareil alors c'est
quand ce départ ben écoute c'est pas
prévu au programme non avant le
démarrage de 60 jours 60 nuits
vous avez déclaré je suis fier de faire
partie de cette aventure qui va
révolutionner la télévision française
cette semaine marc et toi ça me fait
marrer oui parce qu'aujourd'hui ce qui
m'intéresse c'est de savoir ce que vous
déclarez aujourd'hui après la
catastrophe qui a été ce programme mais
je trouve très courageux francis parce
qu'il a les caméras de télé toute la
journée chez lui et le soir il pourra
changer d idée au niveau pétage de
plombs vous êtes plutôt champion du
monde du champion de france
à l'applaudimètre je crois que chez
champion du monde mais il ya un truc
encore pire c'est le buzz cake non quand
vous appuyez le bun cac non mais ça
c'est en fait c'est un terme pour nous
tu dois connaître les résiliations
oui
m
khassawneh comme le sauveur la main sur
un vrai terrain
alors pourquoi est-ce que c'est du
reggae électronique du ragga ou du jump
up c'est du dancehall assez du 2 1
[Applaudissements]
des tournois
le destin de l'émission descellant
cp barré par messieurs change
et j'accueille maintenant roland dumas
non
[Musique]
oui
non
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
roland dumas bonsoir bonsoir vous avez
l'air en forme vous n'avez plus besoin
de la can qui vous aider lors de votre
procès oui je vais opérer
c'est pour elle un procès c'est parce
que j'avais taupe est alors c'était pas
pour attendrir les juges non non il y
avait fabriqué les attend un vainqueur
physiquement ça a l'air d'aller
moralement comment ça va ça va ça va
beaucoup mieux depuis le depuis la
dernière décision ça va beaucoup mieux
ben oui effectivement vous avez été
totalement blanchi donc par les juges de
la cour d'appel de paris dans l'affairé
elf le 29 janvier dernier après 52
tempête judiciaire vous avez été relaxés
innocenté d'être soulagé c'est fini oui
50 cauchemar pendant lesquelles vous
avez continué envers et contre tout à
poursuivre votre enquête sur votre
affaire vous publié aujourd'hui un livre
chez michel lafon qui s'appelle
l'épreuve l'épreuve
[Musique]
alors roland du moins donc relaxé le 29
janvier mais condamné en première
instance donc à six mois de prison ferme
et deux ans et demi avec sursis pour
avoir profité dizaine accusations d'une
partie des fonds versés par elf à
christine deviers-joncour le fameux
appartement de la rue de lille
les chaussures de berluti à onze mille
francs les six statuettes pour cent
cinquante mille francs
le livre de christine deviers joncour la
[ __ ] de la république
et puis la cavale de cervelle qui
menaçaient de faire sauter la république
tout ça c'est ce qu'on a appelé la
sphère dumas ça vous a quand même obligé
cette affaire a démissionné de votre
poste de président du conseil
constitutionnel
oui oui c'est fut douloureux mais
j'étais à bout aujourd'hui vous êtes
relaxé
vous regrettez d'avoir démissionné à
l'époque parce que vous pourriez
toujours à être président du conseil qui
ont ils si oui mais j'ai pris la
décision moi même parce que je n'ai pas
voulu que l'institution ait eu à
souffrir de cet épisode
donc j'ai pris mes responsabilités vous
regrettez pas en ont alors à l'époque
vous parliez de torture de gouttes d'eau
chinoise le fameux supplice faut dire
que personne vous à épargner roland
dumas pas vos amis politiques en tous
les cas de neige aux pas vous a pas
aidés à l'époque il aurait pu faire plus
loin au mieux ouais alors ils étaient
battus aux élections
vous dites qu'il avait ni l'ampleur ni
la carrure pour être président je
l'avais dit longtemps la vence depuis
l'époque où il se présentait comme ça
sur les tréteaux j'avais observé son
comportement à l'égard de l'ancien
président de la république je n'ai
jamais admis le bénéfice d'inventaire
quant aux tirs je considère que ce n'est
pas digne du successeur de françois
mitterrand
je les dis et puis des faits m'ont donné
raison dominique strauss kahn nous a pas
aidés au dos mister kahn aussi longtemps
qu'il n'était pas lui un concernés
avaient une attitude un peu hautaine et
il aura battu son quartier par la suite
fait il a eu lui aussi à faire face à
une même genre de situation relaxé lui
aussi derrière alors pas épargnés non
plus par votre ancienne maîtresse
christine deviers-joncour gros déballage
de votre vie privée c'est ça doit être
terrible salon wii u noter les temps ont
changé on peut parler de ces choses des
moeurs sont plus les mêmes
je la laisse à son destin maintenant
elle va devoir reparaître recond
paraître et reparaître donc faut pas
accabler les gens qui sont dans la
difficulté
vous n'êtes pas tendre avec elle à votre
livre vous parlez d'une image où elle
est c'est l'été elle est dans un jardin
on comprend que les pas très habillée et
elle tient un tuyau d'arrosage à la main
c'est une allégorie non non j'ai décrit
surtout le le contexte périgourdin
j'étais candidat dans cette
circonscription j'ai été accueilli par
cette famille très très très charmante
et très agréable père instituteur la
mère institutrice
bon on faisait des emplettes aux truffes
faisait des dégâts tôt châtaignes enfin
je veux dire c'est étrange je n'ai pas
de regret de cette cette période
ouais mais de méchants quand même de
temps en temps sur un cas avec christine
deviers-joncour vous quand vous parlez
de la rue de lille vous parler de deux
passages vous dites parfois quelques
heures parfois une nuit donc vous la
météo au même rang qu'un certain nombre
d'autres d'autres femmes savez je n'aime
pas beaucoup de temps pour moi si vous
imaginez le travail du décrit dans le
livre le travail de venise affaires
étrangères surtout dans ces années 90 et
suivantes
pourrais je passais une large prenait un
café je reparte
non sérieusement on arrive à
l'impression vous voulez la réduire au
rang d'une femme parmi d'autres quoi cjg
en grande maîtresse de roland dumas et
on a l'impression qu'ils ont lu le
bouquin
d'ailleurs quand elle prend un nouvel
amant le fameux ciara si vous vous en
foutez quoi mais c'est un peu de votre
faute retiendrai ont par l'accueil que
vous l'aviez réservés c'est vous c'est
vous qui est responsable mais pas moins
c'est vous elle m'avait eu un peu elle
était arrivée elle est très forte à elle
était arrivée un peu à me subvertir si
on m'avait dit mais tu es amoureux
d'elle ou quoi et c'est vrai qu'elle
était allée malina voilà mais c'est vous
qui avez trouvé l'expliqué nous sommes
deux et pas moi alors je n'ai pas été
épargné non plus par les juges à eva
joly
une vraie détestation pour elle laurence
vichnievsky aussi vous dites ils sont
imbus d'elle-même soucieuse de publicité
et acharné finalement à abattre le
dernier ou
dignitaires de la mitterrandie vous vous
sentez chez elle quelque chose de
personnel j'ai senti j'ai senti la renie
pour ne pas dire la haine ce qui est
très proche et le parti pris alors que
ça doit pas exister tant elle dans
l'esprit d'un juge ne s'était
systématique
prenez pour argent comptant tout ce
qu'il avait dans une lettre anonyme par
exemple jallet jaillit quelques exemples
avec l'histoire du château de gordes que
j'aurais donné à une dame pour la faire
taire sur le président françois
mitterrand alors que j'ai visé de
regarder au cas d'asthme pour que ce
n'était pas elle vous dit j'étais
coureur j'étais riche j'étais
mitterrandien ge était franc maçon c'est
peut-être ça qui énervait eva joly c'est
ce qu'elle a crû durant le manipuler un
objet devant moi comme ça en ricanant et
puis après la guerre mais des français à
l'époque vaut aussi alors pas épargnés
non plus par les journalistes le général
pas tous les jours à l'entraînement vous
dit henry 15e 138 article sur l' affaire
elf et 119 sur vous exactement avec
libération aussi qui suivait un petit
peu suivi star rue 80 un article sur elf
67 sur vous oui c'est une bonne pension
vrai et surtout avec les idées des
plaines première page à 14h30 tous les
jours on apporter c'est vrai on a
apporté le ceva le monde avec ce qui me
l'apporté été tremblant confus gêné mais
c'était systématique mais pourquoi le
rsa abbas alors là il ya plusieurs
explications restent d'autres livres
paraissent actuellement sur le même
journal qui en disent long qui en avril
long sur les procédés j'ai été je crois
une leurs victimes privilégiées
parce que sont au nombre des éléments
étaient réunis d'abord il y avait une
querelle depuis longtemps qui existait
entre françois mitterrand le monde au
point que mitterrand avait fait
supprimer tous les tous les abonnements
au journal
pendant qu'il était
à l'élysée et
il y avait le fait que moi j'étais
intraitable sur sur les campagnes votre
contre mitterrand il y avait la sphère
des écoutes 1 sur l'un des directeurs
wiki à raconter tout ça en long en large
donc on peut en parler ça public et que
j'ai refusé de me prêter à ce genre de
de calomnie contre l'ancien président et
donc ça allait plus ça n'est plus
donc voilà tout le monde s'est acharné
sur vous pendant pendant cinq ans et là
la nuit parfois vous êtes seul dans
votre appartement et vous pensé au
suicide
mais oui vous savez quand on est à bout
comme ça que le dos au mur et que l'on
ne sait plus par quel parquet de comment
s'y prendre que tout dérape souvent sous
vos pas et j'ai nourri l'espoir pendant
très longtemps que la vérité allait
surgir déjà à l'instruction et quand
tout allait rentrer dans l'ordre
et quand j'ai vu que ce n'était pas le
cas le désespoir vous gagnez soit vous
gagnez et vous êtes comme pris dans une
spirale vous perdez le sommeil c'est pas
autre chose penser pas autre chose et
vous recevoir des amis vous voyez bien
qu'ils sont pas ils sont pas dans la
conversation ils sont pas dans le
contact vous parle pas librement comme
on le fait maintenant et de l'étude de
mal gagne
et puis un beau jour il faut que vous
saisissiez c'est ce qui s'est produit
vous pensez que vous pouvez rigaud voit
dans ces cas là et là j'ai écrit tout un
chapitre
cela va peut-être vous intéressé de
savoir que le chapitre sur bérégovoy qui
figure à la fin de mon livre c'est ce
que j'ai écrit en premier je ne sais pas
pourquoi j'ai commencé par raconter
l'histoire d'un goy qui siège
actuellement au conseil des ministres et
dont j'ai vu petit petit à petit comment
ils se il se vider sa fraise son énergie
le pire moment c'était quoi
c'est alors que j'attendais comme une
décision qui aurait réglé les problèmes
en là j'ai appris que j'étais renvoyé
devant le tribunal correctionnel ou des
dossiers la hollande humains à ce moment
là vous vous dites je dis c'est que
cette fois on veut vraiment mais
vraiment battre et c'est un peu là où
j'ai commencé à un désespéré en la
question évidemment c'est qui pourquoi
alors dans le livre
vous affirmez que vous avez été balancé
pour faire diversion quand on commençait
à s'intéresser de trop près aux
pratiques sérieuse de elf
vous pensez que c'est ça je pense que
quand j'en parlais des chaussures de
dumas il n'ya parlait pas des gros
trafic
il ya un concours de circonstances un
franco tient constante de rencontre même
il y avait vite à danser grosse affaire
dont on va peut-être connaître un petit
bout en ce qui concerne f puisque
l'ouvreur français va venir il y avait
cette affaire des frégates dont j'espère
que le juge qui maintenant le dossier va
faire son va-tout à faire son travail
convenablement en ce qu'il peut dire sur
l' affaire des frégates donc c'est des
frégates qui ont été vendues à taïwan
vous vous opposiez à cette vente
et c'est vrai que monsieur gomez alain
gomez le patron de thomson qui est
devenu thales depuis
s'il a vendu ses frégates à taïwan ça
lui a permis de devenir numéro 1 devant
lagardère pourrait donc lui pour lui
c'est une vraie obsession campsas doublé
de la querelle avec la garde et que je
n'avais pas été épargné par les coups de
ceux de ce fait dès ce mois puisque
j'étais en travers de la faire j'étais
le seul contre bonnes raisons de
politique très simple je disais on va
faire deux politiques à la fois on a on
a nous comment dirais-je une alliance
avec le parti communiste chinois
d'américains populaire et continental et
on ne peut pas en même temps rêvé à une
politique avec leurs adversaires d'hier
a longuement des nationalistes donc
vendre des frégates aux ennemis loin
mais pendant toute cette période il est
évident connaissent essayer de
m'atteindre pour me faire changer d'avis
alors on a essayé par des méthodes de la
séduction dont vous parlez ce qui n'a
rien donné
ce qui n'a rien donné c'est vrai faux et
ensuite par là mais neuf par la menace
c'est à dire je me mêlais un peu trop de
ce qui est des gens est plutôt que de
ceux de s'occuper des lettres anonymes
qui arrive et on s'occupait de buco de
mes chaussures laissées sur onze mille
balles sa frappe l'imagination des gens
oui mais c'est son départ écoutez vous
voulez pas que je géant j'ai été opéré
je sais non non non mais j'ai été opérée
les pères et j'avais la nécessité faire
fin des chaussures bien ce qu'il en est
oui alors c'est cette vallée sociaux en
général mais c'est que ça existe c'est
vers les assets
et sur mesure monsieur sasp est alors
dite dont l' affaire des frégates vous
dit quand même que les preuves des
commissions versées sur la vente des
frégates à taïwan existent elles sont à
bercy mais protégé par le secret défense
voilà pourquoi parce que le secret
défense malgré la création d'une
commission dépend des principaux
ministres ils seront de la défense
nationale ministre des finances en vous
observerez que la question par le juge a
été posé une première fois un ministre
des finances de gauche et qui à dire non
ce que des frères et il l'a reposé à son
successeur des finances de droite et qui
a dit pas question secret défense
bon vous avez succès dans ses 5 en
déduisait que tout le monde l'a touché
du pognon ben moi c'est vous qui le
dites faciles à dénouer l'horrible que
que l'état protège ses marchés sa
fabrication ces contrats d'armement
c'est normal mais que ceci étant on en
profite pour étendre secret défense
l'utiliser à tout propos des verts
notamment quand on cherche les
commissions pur fait du retour dans la
pool tôt le bain d'une association et
caetera et qu'on dise secret défense
la firme apple n'a plus de toit la
vérité vous la savez vous je la subodore
ou plus que je la supporte or je l'avais
je dirais je la côte est ne pouvais pas
le dire je le savais où est partie le
pognon des blés gâte de taille
je suis pas tombée des ingénieurs à main
armée dont vous savez oui alors donc il
y avait l'histoire de lg évidemment avec
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent qui
circulaient les commissions sur les
frégates à taïwan et puis aussi les
services secrets israéliens américains
qui n'aimait pas du tout votre politique
proche orientale parce qu'il faut bien
le dire
reste quand même pro-arabe d'une
certaine façon non
10 c'est vrai que j'ai essayé d'avoir
une politique équilibrée juste et
raisonnable quand les américains sont
les bombarder tripoli
vous avez refusé que les avions
américains survolent la france ce qui a
permis à kadhafi parce qu'il fait en
espagne aller se cacher quand mary et
adam il n'a pas été ce cachet avant le
hasard a fait que les avions sont
arrivés avec une heure de retard est et
entre temps il avait changé le lieu
comme celui-là
alors non la vérité c'est que je me suis
heurté à l'administration américaine
comme on dit un peu comme aujourd'hui le
les autorités françaises sont dans la
même situation après coeur à la
situation
alors aujourd'hui donc vous êtes blanchi
mais vous allez continuer votre enquête
et continuer à travailler sur votre
propre à faire j'imagine mais il ya une
question qui se pose au lendemain
et si finalement la relaxe en appel
n'était pas tout simplement qu'un renvoi
d'ascenseur de chirac à qui vous avez
accordé l'immunité
quand vous étiez encore président du
conseil constitutionnel
[Musique]
je vous écoute présenter les choses
comme ça c'est une infamie
ouais oui c'est une famille parce que
c'est un mépris total à l'égard des neuf
membres du conseil constitutionnel venus
d'horizons différents honnête et bon
juriste qui ont prononcé une décision
sans que je les y force qui était
conforme au droit et imaginer que l'on
peut faire un contrat du genre je te
protège te protège avec le président de
la république ça relève quand même où la
grande fantaisie ou de l'infamie
ajoute-t-on pour clore ce chapitre que
la même question a été soumise quelques
mois après la cour de cassation sur
lequel j'avais pas bar et que je ne
résidait pas et qu'elle ait mis
exactement la même opinion dans les
mêmes termes on rallume
merci
roland dumas maintenant on passe à
l'époque actuelle parce que vous avez
été pendant de nombreuses années
ministre des affaires étrangères quel
avis portez vous aujourd'hui sur la
politique de dominique de villepin et
jacques chirac
écoutez moi je trouve que le
gouvernement enfin le président de la
république de se débrouille pas mal du
tout à partir du moment où il a fait le
forcing jusqu'à présent et que la
question du droit de veto s'opposent
le seul inconvénient quand il courait le
risque c'était de se retrouver lui isolé
voilà ce moment là il est loin de là
il n'est pas isolé dans le cantal et
assurerait donc si effectivement les
trois partenaires principaux puisque
l'allemagne n'est pas membre du conseil
sécurité
les trois partenaires décident de mettre
tous ensemble je veux dire c'est
important pour la cause de la met alors
en 1944 roland dumas votre père a été
fusillé par là par la gestapo
vous étiez à l'époque étudiant en droit
vous êtes entré dans la résistance vous
avez été décoré à la fin de la guerre
quel regard porte le rolland de l'époque
sur le dumas d'aujourd'hui vous pensez
pas que vous étiez un peu trop jouisseur
un peu trop profiteurs et que ça vous ac
mais c'est cher c'est peut-être aussi la
conséquence de deux des difficultés de
la jeunesse et des dangers que l'on a
connu ouais et en même temps du courage
qu'on a eue de se faire une vie enfin
poignet mais je me rappelle une phrase
de mendès-france qui me parlait de sa
guerre quand il était dans l'est dans
l'aviation bombardements à londres vous
savez pas si le lendemain soit encore
vivant alors on en profitait pour vivre
ouais qu'est-ce qu'elle était le plus
dur c'est lé moment pendant la sphère
elf 10 ans ou le maquis en haute vienne
quand on a le maquis il y en avait 20
ans ouais alors c'était s'était déjà
autre chose on avait la vie devant soi
on peut dire là ce que vous avez
aujourd'hui mais bien sûr que vous êtes
très frère merci
ouais non mais dites le contraire 80 ans
mais là messieurs
et merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
le bouquin s'appelle épreuve l'épreuve
s'est évitée chez michel lafon
merci au lendemain merci madame
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
m
voici mon avis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lors d'un petit mail à messieurs
n'infirmons soir bonsoir
alors bienvenue laurent dans l'émission
qui tient tête au programme américain
les experts sur tf1 et baffie contre les
vampires sur m6 ah oui j'ai participé à
se donner sous un pseudonyme m les
enfants ça va ça va très bien ouais ça
va très bien que quand brasse et ton
chien et bien joué ça va mieux parce
qu'à l'heure où la nouba été opéré on
lui a retiré et oui on en a mais vous
rigolez montlieu retirer lui tire lui ça
alors c'est quand même une opération
alors chez une famille une semaine de
cligner qu'elle était à la maison deux
heures après ouais alors moi je suis un
mec qui m'a demandé une question pour
toi il dit est ce que laurent baffie en
a pas marre de faire semblant d'être
méchant alors qu'il oublie juste de
sourire
oui oui c'est une bonne question est
belle c'est vrai que l'on manque de
bonnes questions dans cette émission
fait partie c'est une bonne question
disant tu veux pas me prendre corti là
pendant une semaine ils seraient
aujourd'hui le mois qu'est-ce que
j'entretiens ma jambe le plus bas ces
gens fassent de corps d'un agent peu
plus encore lui ça va mais les [ __ ] on
les met au travail
est-ce que sur quelques questions tu
veux qu'on termine cet échange là moi je
sais que tu es content mais j'aimerais
te l'entendre dire tirer ce que tu peux
nous confirmer qu'elle contre la guerre
comme tout le monde ici je suis
absolument contre la grille je trouve
qu'on ne le dit pas assez
j'ai une chanson j'ai une chanson qui
cassent bien george bush
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on sait
il est tout
très courte
c
alors mesdames messieurs
ok
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant
c'est beau
[Musique]
voici m'intrigue well
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
passé par là
alors patrick vous sortez du théâtre de
la madeleine vous interprétez le limier
avec jacques weber
c'est un triomphe vous êtes là très en
forme
comment vous faites c'est vrai que c'est
pas compliqué d'arriver comme sortir de
scène et d'arrivée des pignons
finalement non je me suis dit ça tout à
l'heure la sortie de scène c'est ce
qu'on peut passer de l'un à l'autre et
bien évidemment qu'il faut passer de
l'un à l'autre
ouais l'asie continue c'est une
obligation le lit mais on regarde à quoi
ça ressemble magnéto serge j'ai rien
contre votre union avec marguerite des
mon voeu le plus cher est de vous voir
ensemble tous les deux seulement on
n'éclaire pas seulement pour deux
petites semaines et qu american est
ainsi devenu un sport national dans ce
pays se moquer des gens qui s'aiment
je me bats pour je suis sceptique c'est
tout le bétail qui baissent pas fameux
va recevoir la médaille tout pour une
white citoyens tu gagnes tu restes tu
perds tu perds tout l'important dans le
jeu c'était d'y prendre part
mon père l'a pris par et le père de mon
père est au grand père de mon père est
alors ma famille sont toujours perdus et
ça s'arrête avec moi
[Applaudissements]
la troupe belge albert frère
alors à la 150e début février il y avait
déjà plus de cent mille spectateurs qui
étaient venus voir la pièce ce qui est
énorme
et comme dirait mon ami laurent ruquier
la presse est unanime elle combats de
monstres le figmag bruel la surprise est
totale est très heureuse valeurs
actuelles
bruel est excellent le parisien pari
gagné bruel joue se farde se travestit
et l'on n'y croit le figaro france soir
bruel est bluffant s'appelle mangé son
pain blanc c'est très agréable pour une
rentrée au théâtre ça fait très
longtemps que j'en ai pas fait devant
c'est flatteur c'est très encourageant
pour continuer à prendre des risques et
de la centrale les parties qu'une avoir
un boulot alors on a mis ça
et m'attends à voir ça parce qu'à aussi
de disques alors ça c'est encore plus
incroyable succès de total avec l'album
entre deux reprises de succès des années
30 et qui sort d'ailleurs en coffret
avec 3 à 3 cd car les deux coffrets du
cd entre deux plus jeunes ajouté un
voisin canadien original on a mis des
versions originales dedans pour vaincre
toutes les gens vous un petit peu ce
qu'on avait fait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà entre 2 le nouveau coffret avec
les trois cd mais la chanson qu'on
entend beaucoup en ce moment c'est avec
charles aznavour c'est ça
c'est là que j'ai laissé mon coeur
c'est là que je viens on va trouver
on a
tout le monde
car je revois ma petite hybride où les
bars corps
ma vie
rizzoli
mais la folie je parle
patry guen mais encore avec shadow
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez demander de
plus à la ville à cette année quel
cadeau ah ouais quel cadeau ils m'ont
monf sdis ses chansons et quelques uns
de hommes ont fait tous ces artistes qui
sont venus sur l'album c'est c'est
vraiment beau ce un très bon moment
ouais ouais bonne entrée c'est très beau
je suis très très heureux et très
chanceux
patrick bauwen est-ce que vous lis je
mets un petit jeu patrick en faire un
petit jeu où vous avez fait un disque
était un succès énorme qui reprend
beaucoup de chansons des années 30 qui
s'appelle entre deux je vous propose de
faire une interview à métro
[Musique]
donc on est en 1930
d'accord je vois l'image nous
l'indiquent
est ce que je peux vous appeler le môme
boel ouais
est ce que ça marche bien mais les deux
montants ça ça se défend je vais le
faire ce duo avec charles trenet prenez
ce petit jeune l'arrêt n'y a pas le
temps
il est sympa saint wendel ouais il en
fait un peu trop de temps en temps mais
on dit qu renoir pensé à vous pour la
règle du jeu c'est vrai je suis pas sûr
d'être libre
bon c'est que vaille le renouveau de la
castagne peut également au nom nord qui
regarde tout le monde va bien tout va
mais on est on est bien on est peinards
les pas de problème les gens s'aiment
bien non c'est des trucs qui raconte
dans les gens voudraient que l'algérie
va toujours rester française
[Musique]
au faouët bien visionner pour penser
comment ouais
[Musique]
et maintenant voici le nom d'allah
vient alors dans l'amont soir vous
connaissez saint thiébaut elles n'ont se
rencontrent comment ça va chanter comme
ça il va tout de suite trouvé les mots
qu'il fallait vous connaissez laurent
baffie ouais ouais bouge pas alors le
but milliers de caisses que la dynamique
elle m'a très bien la nar tu sais quoi
j'ai ouvert ma loge et j'ai chialé c'est
tout ah ouais je suis allé pendant 20
ans en fait tu as l'air d'un durement
fait que très tôt là bas j'imagine alors
les honneurs vous êtes l'exemple vivant
de la beauté des mélanges et du
métissage
votre père et chiliens votre mère et
2000 juive hongroise votre grand père
maternel indien fait c'est un
melting-pot à vous tout seul et vous
êtes de nationalité française et vous
parlait d'ailleurs très très bien le
français
merci vous êtes un petit peu le
prototype de ses filles dans tous les
hommes sont fous maintenant c'est à dire
les bombes latines quoi écouter mais en
prime time vers les américains vous
surnomme el nuevo symbôle au ce et soual
j'aime bien chez moi est ce que tu veux
est ce que c'est que ce sera quand on
havre actuel fait sa gamme
ça partait à la paire 6 alors les
honneurs vous êtes venu au grand écran
par le petit voilà vous êtes fort
célèbre à travers une une série qui
s'appelle cleopatra vous vous incarniez
le rôle titre de la série a fait un
tabac sur la chaîne américaine nbc 1 tu
connais cleopatra je n'ai pas les
haussiers sur cette actrice voilà
squeezer dossier adore mellinet ce qu'on
peut amener un verre d'eau devant les
honneurs comme ça si vraiment il la
gonfle alors on n'est pas l'abri de
prendre un verre dans sur la galerie sk
lors elle a promis des boules puantes à
l'image donc je disais que j'étais venu
vous étiez venu au grand écran par un
petit à travers une série qui s'appelle
cléopâtre house incarné le rôle titre
qui a fait un tabac sur la chaîne
américaine nbc ensuite j'ai fait l'homme
au masque de fer avec leonardo dicaprio
blake tout et on vous verra en octobre
prochain dans une comédie la nouvelle
comédie de francis veber qui s'appelle
les tourtereaux avec gérard depardieu et
jean reno voilà pour l'instant vous et l
affiche de pas si grave de bernard rapp
avec romain duris sami bouajila et jean
michel portal voilà c'est bien comme
présentation le seul c'est plutôt gentil
je n'étais pas sûr que ça alors je fais
le pitch mêmes moyens c'est l'histoire
de trois frères dont un coffret
radcliffe qui vivent en belgique
le père est espagnol et il n'est pas
retourné en espagne depuis la guerre
civile parce qu'il est exilé évidemment
et alors il demande à ses trois fils
adoptif de venir d'urgence à son chevet
et puis un petit peu comme un dernier
veut avant de mourir il leur donne comme
mission d'aller chercher une statuette
une vierge dans les yeux pleurent des
larmes de sang
une statuette qui est caché dans un
placard des locaux de la guardia civil
voilà comme vous avez fumé
non non c'est bernard rapp avant c'est
marrant j'aurais jamais cru bernard a pu
fumer
mais c'est vrai que les trois frères
quittent la belgique pour l'espagne et
quand ils arrivent ils tombent sur vous
personnage quand même assez libertin
puisque vous donner quand même deux
frères au moins sur trois noms disant
libérez plutôt que du bertin on vous
voit deux fois nue dans le film
oui c'est vrai c'est vrai oui pour ça
faut y aller regarder quoi ça ressemble
les deux fois nié d'auxerre comment j'y
vais pas jeannard à l'affût de l'espagne
semaines pas un jour de plus
on entre on demande à voir le commandant
on lui dit que notre pablo il veut sa
statue et s'il est pas content pour une
branlée à tout le bataillon pièce coup
c'est vous qui t'a envoyé palpable qui
menace et ses fils
[Musique]
est ce que tu as appris à mettre des
coups de boule comme ça là chez les
soeurs le truc de la bâche là bas car
d'un café et shakespeare un peignoir des
parents espagnols on a foutu dire trois
mois toi t'es un mec ou tuer encore
jetés faire trop de boulot tu fais quoi
je travaille à l'hôpital
[ __ ] meilleurs chirurgiens la reine du
bistouri
[Musique]
croyez pas qu'on est en train de faire
une connerie aurait peut-être mais
maintenant que c'est parti c'est parti
j'aime bien l'idée de faire le 15 mai
15e défi on pensait pas que vous
rentrerez aussitôt si ça n'aboutit qu'à
toi on aurait tout laisser tomber des
débuts alors tu écrases et cherche en
vain comme ça votre problème c'est que
depuis la première seconde vous êtes
tous les deux résidents de bonne chère
pas toi peut-être banon par mois qu'est
ce qu'il raconte est ce que nous quoi a
dit que c'est la première fois qu'il
voit des français qui savent même pas de
café quand il est chez ceux qui les fait
rire c'est que les français comme john
et la gare bienvenue en espèces voilà
pas si grave bernard ans avec les
honneurs en est là qui m'ont invité ce
soir donc dans le film j'ai appelé
angela but dit angela et angélique c'est
vrai que c'est un petit peu une fée non
elle est un petit peu la révélatrice et
joue un peu le rôle de louis ii de
l'alchimiste fin révélatrice parce que
elle va elle va aider ces garçons à se
libérer à se trouver au même
ouais mais comment ça finit bien la
morale du film normal dans une morale du
film c'est qu'en fait le le père est pas
si malade que ça et en fait il a fait
tout ça pour rapprocher ces trois ses
trois enfants s'était pas pour les
projeter dans son sassine vers leur
avenir
absolument moi je trouve c'est une très
jolie façon d'aborder des choses qui
sont assez profondes comme la fratrie
comme la dette envers ses parents et
comme la recherche de soi d'une façon
très légère et ludique qui est un peu un
peu là où bernard surprend parce que
après deux films très grave il se prend
un qui est passée grave justement vous
avez flashé sur bernard a parfaitement
c'est un être qui qui qui est exquis qui
drôle sympathique et est intelligent et
ça c'est vraiment un super type
d'ailleurs dans le métier il ya peu de
gens qui ont cette réputation quand on
dit bernard c'est toi c'est pas rien
quoi si c'est un bon gars alors les
honneurs vous vivez entre los angeles et
paris et quand vous étiez enfant vous
avez vécu au chili au costa rica aux
états unis en allemagne en france
fugain furieuse une enfance
effectivement assez vagabonde qui a été
la source chez vous on peut le dire
d'une instabilité assez profonde
je crois qu'il contenait enfants
l'instabilité oui fait qu'on se réfugie
d'une manière d'une autre plus dans son
monde intérieur et moi j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir un nul familial proche très très
très fort et et des parents
extraordinaires qui ont vraiment nous
ont aidés à passer tous ses cadres de
changement vous avez déclaré
où que je sois le reste me manque quand
tu es tu fasses je pense à toi c'est toi
aussi
donc je confonds là c'est goldman c'est
à dire que quand je suis en france je me
sens vraiment bien
après notamment mais le chili me manque
et
et los angeles ne manque et quand je
suis la balle tu vois ça c'est pas
facile pour les histoires d'amour de
bouger autant non non ça c'est pas
évident ouais c'est pas évident c'est
mal passé avec votre fiancée là non
c'est pas mal passé d'ailleurs on se
parle à peu près tout ou tous les mois
votre fiancé c'est le fameux billy zane
dont des ctc c'était voilà oui avant
c'est fini c'était antoine dans le
cléopâtre ah bah oui c'est fini
les gardes à gauche qui quand elle est
là l usap a pris pour son film par
exemple est en train de réaliser un film
dans le midi de la france il vous a pas
j'étais censé le faire mais j'ai trouvé
ça un petit peu compliqué d'être dirigée
par mon ex
ouais ouais oui et non ça vous a pas plu
gg je les aime beaucoup et on s'entend
bien
en tant que tigo qu'être qu'être libre
mais dans un rapport de metteur en scène
et acteur je pense qu'il ya beaucoup
d'autres choses qui rentrent en jeu je
pense qu'on n'était pas encore prêt à
aller là c'est trop frais quoi il aurait
fallu attendre du ray contenant ces
régions devraient pas tarder à le gérer
le célibataire là oui je suis
célibataire mais pas tous attirés comme
ça je dois vous croyez encore au prince
charmant oui c'est assez antho mais
c'est vrai qu'on appelle ça marche aussi
non mais c'est vrai que je crois je
crois en l'amour je crois que je crois
dans couple je crois surtout dans la
famille je crois j'ai envie d'enfant et
j'ai envie de construire
voilà merci tu as fait il a toujours le
mot qui toujours et en plus il a des
paillettes dans sa loge
bayer pour faire des enfants qui a tous
je sais que tu vas tout
donc vous êtes un petit peu tout seul et
vous vous réfugiez dans le bouddhisme
je ne me réfugie pas dans le bouddhisme
ggd par an bouddhiste donc j'ai grandi
avec cette philosophie autour de moi et
c'est vrai qu'une grande partie de mon
temps
seuls ceux se déroulant une recherche
l'on peut dire mystique co spirituelle
qui est très important dans ma vie oui
c'est vos parents votre sympathie aux
états unis à boulder colorado et yavin
communauté disant bouddhistes et et
votre père qui était un scientifique de
haut niveau est devenu bouddhiste et et
votre mère s'est mis à la méditation la
thérapie corporelle au tissage de la
laine est mal quoi des vrais bab
d'ailleurs vous venez de passer là vous
ne passez du temps dans un dans un
ashram en inde 10 heures de méditation
par jour
ça fait du bien de couper un peu avec
tous ses ce milieu a parfois un peu un
petit peu superficiel aux parents sont
arrivés à lignan 73 oui on est parti
après le coup de tabac oui absolument
moi j'étais à peine bébé et on était
littéralement balancé par dessus le mur
de l'ambassade
mon père a été un torturé mon oncle
faisait partie du gouvernement donc on
est parti vraiment en trombe
j'ai un grand père qui a disparu oui mon
grand père maternel qui était
travailleur social est très engagé
politiquement oui et vous pensez quoi du
sort qui a été réservé à pinochet à la
fin moi j'étais très personnelle mais je
crois que à ce niveau et à son âge il
nous reste plus que la compassion quoi
ça m'a tellement misérable un mec
tellement excusez moi un maire 2 qu' on
peut on peut qu'est ce qu'on va lui
faire on va enfermer le reste de ces
pauvres années qui lui restent
j'étais ravie comme de voir que il a été
jugé qu' on la met sur une barre et on
l'a
la vérité quand même un petit peu sorti
ça je crois aidé énormément beaucoup
beaucoup de gens à retrouver une
certaine vérité incertaine sens de
revanche
je n'aime pas trop le mot mais quand
même certain sens de justice lilloise il
a
michel portal la mesure
m
alors vous savez qu'aujourd'hui c'est le
8 mars c'est la journée de la femme
la journée de la femme qui a été inventé
au danemark en 1910 et qui n'est devenu
officiel en france qu'en 1982 grâce à
yvette roudy valence demander à quoi
avait servi yvette roudy
elle a fait ça alors il ya plein de
manifestations culturelles et politiques
comme la marche des femmes des cités et
puis il ya aussi l'adjoint à la culture
au maire de paris
monsieur delanoë christophe girard ils
avaient une idée pour la journée de la
femme que tu es vachement bien c'est
qu'on parle au féminin toute la journée
c'est pas ridicule c'est bien dit
bonjour je suis contente constructif
comment elle va je connais pas un
endroit ils font déjà ça oui au mathis
ça tous les soirs
comment elle va là bruel elle se porte
bien bien alors voilà donc l plein
d'idées comme ça et le magazine elle a
eu l'idée de profiter de la journée de
la femme pour organiser les états
généraux de l'homme alors le résultat
des états généraux de l'homme c'est
grave pour nous les mac 1 c'est assez
préoccupant c'est un peu ça ouais m'ont
dit que je suis voilà un peu dans quelle
situation nous sommes nous les hommes
d'aujourd'hui et pour en savoir plus
j'accueille la rédactrice en chef de
elle j'accueille valérie toranian
bonsoir
bonsoir valérie bon souvenir le plus dur
est fait voilà là il m'avait dit le plus
dur chez les pêcheurs 10 ans est de
descendre les marches
ça s'est très très bien passé quelle a
été la méthode pour ces états généraux
de l'homme comment avez vous sonder les
âmes
alors nous on pensait qu'il était temps
de les sonder parce qu'on avait le
sentiment que tout allait passer bien du
côté des hommes vous voyez bien
connaître dans un moment où la méfiance
la distance le désarroi étaient visibles
perceptible on s'est dit c'est le moment
d'aller creuser voir ce qui se passe
alors on pressentait le malaise mais ce
qu'on a eu ça a été c'était au delà de
ce qu'on avait pu imaginer au gaz gis
dragin de la part des cris de rage
beaucoup de colère du désarroi du
ressentiment des frustrations voilà donc
cédant lundi avec patrick bruel en
couverture
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et ce soir nous en parlons avec de
petits seins bien sage de clementi
le
degrémont dit voici que martin autant
[Musique]
clémentine bonsoir donc vous êtes
adjointe au maire de paris chargé de la
jeunesse vous êtes titulaire d'un dea
d'histoire sur le mlf et vous êtes co
fondatrice d'une association féministe
mixte vous êtes auteur d'alter ego chez
laffont et aujourd'hui vous publiez les
droits des femmes
l'inégalité en question aux éditions
essentiel milan
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors vous dites quand vous parlez des
magazines féminins il libère les femmes
autant qu'ils répercutent les messages
sexistes
effectivement je crois qu on plane un
peu dans la schizophrénie avec cette
double dimension de temps en temps on
parle des violences conjugales et puis
la page d'après il faut faire un régime
pour surtout ressemble moi je pense que
le paradoxe la contradiction c'est
absolument féminin et qu' il faut un peu
salée j'ai la tête par rapport à tout ça
la vie est comme ça les femmes sont
comme ça les hommes aussi d'ailleurs je
demande pas d'intervenir laisser un
petit peu débattre toute façon pour
débattre on accueille deux hommes de
plus c'est normal voici yann moix et
nicolas rey
[Musique]
bonsoir vous êtes chroniqueurs vous êtes
écrivain et depuis quelques semaines
réalisateur puisque vous porter à
l'écran le roman je vais écrire chez
grasset qui s'appelle podium ça qui
parle de claude françois de la
mythologie claude françois désy france
soir avec poelvoorde et jean paul rouve
ça et julie depardieu et julie depardieu
ça finit quand cela encore cinq semaines
de tournage on est à la moitié il ya 11
semaines en tout c'est que mardi
prochain anniversaire de la mort de
claude françois mais oui bien sûr rien
de spécial
non mais on va aller tourner quelques
scènes au moulin de dannemois besoin y
avait un gros happening claudien la
barre alors nicolas rêve d'être
chroniqueur au figaro à france 3 chez
franz olivier giesbert culture et
dépendances
vous êtes écrivain est votre troisième
roman qui s'appelle un début prometteur
au diable vauvert a rencontré des
critiques assez élogieuse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
c'est un peu usés
alors j'ai relevé quelques phrases dans
votre bouquin qui vont vous faire mal
voir au moins 2 clémentines pourquoi ne
pas la violette à comédienne à l'ombre
d'un pommier
pourquoi ne pas lui faire un mal de
chien calvaire sept personnages bien
entendu enfin quand même si c'est quand
même effroyable pour une fois que je
fais un bouquin un peu humain et
d'attendre la seule phrase limite des
ventes de ce livre vous avez relevé et
ça donne ça pour une fois il ya des
portraits de femmes quand même passé
lorsque paralysie patrick c'est pas vous
patrick sodomise la jeune femme en lui
donnant de lourde claque
pourquoi alors j'ai vous arrive pas
d'accord je vais vous répondre et je
réponde à clémentine avait mis comme ça
en porte-à-faux alors que ouais faut
quand même expliqué on dirait pas il a
une tête d'ange ah mais non mais
justement à ce moment là si c'est la
journée de la femme etc
parlons-en et panne on s'en va en parler
bah oui de la sodomie oui d'accord vous
les comparez ces 2010 alors été de faire
un petit moment sur la sodomie
si vous parlez de la zac cod vision
d'assaut dmitri hétérosexuels oui
justement j'ai quelque chose à dire là
où ça c'est dommage tout c'est moi j'en
parle souvent si tu voulais avec des
avec des garçons et tous les types qu'on
qu'une seule obsession quelque chose
comme ça d' assez hachée pas quasiment
fatigant à force c'est une sorte comme
ça tu d'aboutir à [ __ ] leurs
copines pourquoi toujours arriver à ça
alors moi je leur conseille un truc et
je pense que la clémentine frais
d'accord avec moi ou valérie également
je ne fais pas c'est que ces petits
bonheurs mais avant de type là ceux de
mise leurs copines puisse-t-elle salaire
comme ça d'être une sorte de graal
absolu et ben que leurs copines achète
un gode ceinture que e seul e phase
faire par leurs copines ça donne égalité
le signe d un rapport d'égalité en fait
donc j'adore aller sur un plateau de
télé depuis une minute il a dû reculer
tout le monde c'est pas si ça alors non
mais je vous répondais comme ça la peau
j'ai pas terminé il me répond alors j'ai
pas par l'ena des plans de présupposés
donc moi je n'ai rien contre la sodomie
et non mais que les choses soient quand
même extrêmement clair et je crois que
c'est pas du tout de problème qui est
posé d'abord s'est posé dans un cas très
hétérosexuels et s'il ya des hommes qui
ont envie de [ __ ] leurs copines et
qu'elles sont d'accord je vois pas du
tout où ils souci de dans la symbolique
[ __ ] effectivement qui suis un artiste
je viens gentiment moi j'aime les femmes
au lycée ça je pars je voulais faire
quand on dit [ __ ] quelqu'un c'est
parce que c'est homophobe c'est un mot
qui a pris de cette nature mais bon
voilà
et le côté tendre du bouquin etc non en
fait le fait comme ça le sentiment
amoureux découvrent le narrateur avec ça
dans votre bouquin dont j'ai repris deux
phrases complètement restauré ça va bien
alors on va passer maintenant que j'ai
de elle valérie vous êtes concentré donc
ce que vous racontez enfin ce que
racontent les sommes que vous avez
interviewé c'est la chute de l'empiré
masculin c'est à dire que maintenant les
femmes ont eu leur indépendance je
dirais économies que sexuel révolution
des moeurs égalité des sexes et l'homme
est en crise finalement c'est à dire que
l'homme supporte très mal
la prépondérance qu'ont compris les
femmes dans les dernières décennies
c'est la fin de l'archétype du
patriarche du géniteur du banquier et
finalement il se sent un peu inutile
enfin d'après ce qui ressort évidemment
de l'étude et il nous semble très
dominatrice
oui ils ont l'impression que les valeurs
féminines sont glorifiés partout voilà
que les valeurs masculines sont devenus
ringards
voilà peut être un homme c'est forcément
avoir tout faux et que ça il supporte
plus voilà et dans sept dents voilà dans
cette brèche la chance et des choses
qu'il faut alors patrick non seulement
vous êtes en couverture du elle mais en
plus vous réagissez dans une interview à
cette étude qui a été faite par cca sur
l'attitude des hommes face à cette prise
de pouvoir des femmes
vous réagissez comme ans j'ai été un peu
un peu à l'armée parce que qu'on compte
des notes dans cette étude dans le
discours des hommes de ces hommes là en
tout cas c'est le manque d'amour
le manque de
de faiblesse affichée le manque de
tendresse
le manque de communication
essentiellement de communication et
c'est le petit problème c'est que
peut-être que les femmes ont fait une
avancée fulgurante sans en mesurer les
conséquences et ses conséquences on
positionne l homme dans une dans une
situation de performance qui kg mais
aujourd'hui en grande déstabilisation et
c'est vrai que l'exemple d'un dessin
qu'on pourrait faire 6 i am un
dessinateur plantu pourrait faire un
dessin où on verrait on verrait ainsi
une image avec une femme pose sa tête
sur l'épaule d'un homme et puis quelques
années plus tard on verrait la femme qui
a grandi qui quand elle veut poser la
tête sur l'épaule de l'homme très très
très mal au cou parce qu'elle peut plus
à poser et aujourd'hui donc elle est
insatisfait de pouvoir poser cette
époque est à la fois l'homme ne veut
plus revendiquer qu'il a une épaule très
fort parce que il est tout associé à
quelque chose de fait certaines valeurs
négatives comme le mal de matches malade
et se sont fait je crois parce qu'un
petit peu ce que j'essaie de dire dans
cette interview entre autres que ce sont
les femmes qui vont redonner aux hommes
leur leur puissance et leur élan et
leurs possibilités patrick pousse-t-on
et paul sion ce qui est terrible dans ce
cri que que poussent les hommes dans le
réel donc lundi on voit bien il ya
l'homme objet c'est à dire l'homme objet
ou l'enfant préféré c'est à dire qu'il
ya plus de deux positions
l'homme objet c'est une espèce je dirais
de godemichés vivent un qui est jugé sur
la taille de son pénis
et puis face à des femmes qui sont plus
que libérée qui sont débridés c'est eux
qui parlent qui sont excessives qui ne
savent pas s'arrêter qui veulent jouir
obligatoirement il ya un sexologue mais
c'était dans votre jeunesse dans un
autre qui dit qui est des femmes qui
viennent le voir en me disant ah c'est
un drame j'ai eu que 8 contraction
orgasmique
hier soir c'est quand même un scandale
donc pas question d'être macho parce que
si l'homme est macho il est dénigré et
face à ça il ya ce qu'ils appellent l'
enfant préféré c'est à dire là c'est une
relation complètement presque deux
frères et soeurs de nuque
où l'homme est une femme comme les
autres pour paraphraser le titre du film
de lieberman
l'homme doit intégrer les valeurs
féminines et quand il les a intégrés on
lui reproche son manque de virilité donc
c'est une espèce de contradiction
terrible dans lesquelles se retrouvent
ces hommes ils ont ils disent souvent
qu'ils se ils ont l'impression d'être
devant une femme face à une forme
d'exigence et à des demandes tout le
temps contradictoires mais je voudrais
quand même modérée parce que toutes ces
paroles sont il faut les entendre parce
qu'elle existe donc ça doit être une
réalité
en même temps ça traduit surtout une
angoisse c'est à dire une angoisse eux
sur leur propre manière d'assumer
tranquillement et normalement le fait
d'être un homme face à ça une femme et
il ya je pense dans cette étude ce qui
est peut-être nouveau par rapport à une
étude qui aurait pu être fait par
exemple il ya dix ans est une vraie
angoisse de disparition c'est ce qu'on
appelle nous l'envoie dans la
disparition
c'est à dire non seulement la relation
avec la femme est là elle a poussé le
curseur elle a été très vite il faut
s'adapter et c'est pas évident et c'est
tout ce qu'ils disent est aussi on a
beaucoup de mal on a beaucoup de mal aux
secours et puis en même temps la science
la technologie fait qu'aujourd'hui on
leur parle de clown on leur parle de
deux systèmes de reproduction dont il
pourrait être complètement exclu ça
profondément ça ne doit pas du tout
favoriser une espèce de relation avec la
absolument mais ces déchets la peur de
ne pas voir les choses complexes
la peur de disparaître il faut quand
même préciser quelque chose c'est que
cette enquête a été faite sur un
échantillon de cadres essentiellement de
cadres et de cadres sup
donc j'aimerais qu'on revienne aussi
dans parce que c'est pas les hommes
c'est une enquête
visiblement c'est plutôt le lectorat de
l
grosso modo c'est un peu dans le univers
urbain maîtrisé et c'est donc revenons
aussi à la réalité je veux dire les
questions qu'on se pose là même s'il ya
une crise
non mais même s'il ya les questions qui
sont posées plus de la masculinité jeu
direct malgré tout on a toujours 27 %
l'écart de salaire on a quand même deux
millions de femmes qui sont victimes de
violences conjugales chaque année et
j'ai pas vu qu'ils aient beaucoup
d'hommes qui porte plainte parce qu'ils
sont battus par leurs femmes même si
peut-être ces phénomènes qui vont qui
vont émerger enfin pour l'instant c'est
plutôt la même philosophie reste à
l'impression que vous dites c'est que
tout ça c'est des problèmes de riche en
gros c'est un peu des problèmes de rim
s'est un peu on a le sentiment que c'est
un peu le microcosme parisien qui se
regarde le nombril je ne sais pas si
c'est un microcosme parisien ce qui est
sûr c'est que c'est un laboratoire c'est
à dire de le fait d'avoir sélectionné
des hommes qui sont dans le monde du
travail entre 20 ans entre 20 et 55 ans
qui sont divorcés qui sont acquis sont
tous soit divorcé soir marié aux
familles recomposées soit en couple est
ensuite qu'ils soient cadres moyens ou
cadres c'est vrai que ça imprime une
marque particulière mais notre but c'est
pas de faire un référendum et un sondage
national pour dire aujourd'hui les
hommes c'est ça notre but c'était
d'aller essayer de réfléchir et de
creuser là où on sentait le malaise et
le malaise il est perceptible là pensez
quoi de cette situation dans laquelle
des hommes se retrouvent
je pense que c'est assez juste de dire
que on peut quand on essaie de se
trouver être très castriste
et quand on prend son pouvoir de ne pas
laisser la place à l'homme je vois que
dans ma vie j'ai pu être comme ça je
vois que dans la vie quand j'essaie de
prendre mon pouvoir et ma place on peu
le pas laisser la place à celle de
l'autre et ont fini par être célibataire
jeu ce qui n'est pas un mal un moment
donné de sa vie pour pouvoir se
retrouver
cela dit c'est difficile de généraliser
comme ça je ne me retrouve pas tellement
on va rester sur un malentendu ça
comique
j'ai parlé un petit peu cinq minutes on
va tomber d'accord moi je suis 4g une
formation de cadres dont je rentre dans
le non mais les états généraux s'appelle
la rétine et le but n'est pas de passer
sept buts sous la guillotine comment
passer sa tête à l'époque de la
révolution française
tout ce truc là que mais non mais que
les sommes très heureux avec jallet en
déplacement chez les hommes n'existerait
pas qu'on tombe là dedans je me revois
mais je suis prêt mais que les matières
nobles et s'il vous plaît laissez-les à
s'exprimer s'il vous plaît j'ai la femme
brimée
souvenons nous du matap à claques sur
les fesses
sinon merci voyage d identité on est
d'accord nous achètent bien d'accord
mais en ce moment la tendance est un peu
de dire les femmes maintenant
réussissent partout etc
elles sont formidables est loin de
pouvoir or le truc les femmes mènent le
monde on sait depuis deux siècles
mais faisons attention à ça ce que je
voudrais pas qu'on renverse les rôles et
que maintenant ce soit les femmes qu'ils
soient là oh là là vraiment vous écrase
mais plus droit de chien une petite
tendance huit années lorsqu'on constate
quand même c'est que les hommes
aujourd'hui et ça ça sort de l'étude
vous avez fait avec le laisser ses
cadres soit des papas poules soit des
machos soit des gains soient des exo
gamme
le papa poule basse et le collabo 1
c'est celui qui qui devient une femme
qui deviendra sa soeur de sa femme
le macho c'est celui qui attaque les
femmes qui agressif qui se défend par
l'agressivité le gué bon bah c'est celui
qui vit avec des garçons comme ça il a
passé l'ex logan
maintenant il ya plus en plus d'hommes
qui sont pour l'exogamie c'était 17 voit
très bien dans votre truc tu as qui
préfèrent a épousé des femmes à des
philippines des russes des polonais
plutôt que de supporter les français
donc c'est quand même dur c'est de
l'ordre du fantasme
certes dans l'étude il faut différencier
quand on leur dit mais comment vous
imaginez comment vous fantasmez dans dix
ans dans 20 ans qu'est-ce que ce
pourrait être la relation comment vous
imaginez que seront les femmes il
partout et par tous dans les fantasmes
extrêmement typés et violent ils sont
surtout en train de dire on a beaucoup
de mal à se reconnaître dans ces images
que la société nous imprime la
communication la publicité et que nous
on voudrait sortir c'est de ces
stéréotypes et être accepté dans une
diversité dans une singularité en même
temps il ya des sacs très belles d'antan
théréau type par exemple il suffit de
savoir les centres les transcender
prenez l'exemple des talons aiguilles de
léonore alors c'est vrai on pourrait
dire c'est le cliché c'est s'est du coup
un peu le côté comme sa femme fatale et
tout et en même temps il ya un côté
inabordable et en même temps quand vous
marchez avec des talons aiguilles
c'est un peu précaire comme démarche
parce que non c'est parce qu'on en a à
faire on peut tomber facilement on peut
se casser les chevilles c'est en même
temps ce marché notamment moi femme
aimée marché talons
mancka sans voix c'est vrai que quand on
moins d'un an on dit c'est une fine
cuisine qui parle des choses inabordable
c'est pourquoi on put alors un mot
chacun jan je pense que l'offre doit
être le barycentre delà du romantisme et
de la pornographie puisqu'on a commencé
sur la sodomie qui rien fait
une femme il faut bien la baiser en lui
restant des lexandre 1 en lui offrant
des fleurs quoi d'accord le point
central entre la pornographie le
romantisme d'accord c'est ça qui célèbre
normal un mec normal c'est ça voilà
voilà donc c'est le mec qui est macho
mais qui après une fois que nos craintes
fini le couillon qui vient rester des
poèmes est un mélange de ça
d'accord c'est voilà merci d'une belle
partouze la fête des mères alors on
continue patrick un conseil qu'est-ce
qu'il faut qu'on soit les mecs
moi je pense que je dis dans l'interview
je pense que le lobe même ceux qui le
désiraient que la femme désire ce
qu'elle aime assez bien et que le jour
où l'homme
[Applaudissements]
le jour où l'homme accepta de désiré ce
qu'il aime je pense qu'il a fait un très
grand pas en oeuvre nicolas je pense que
il ya quelque chose de sympa quand même
entre l'homme et la femme c'est le
sentiment amoureux quand ils tombent
amoureux l'un de l'autre
ça permet de mettre quelque chose entre
soi et le monde est de tenir le coup un
peu et d'avoir double dose de vie comme
ça en une journée et où en un mois ou
même parfois en un an
vous savez quand vous croisez quelqu'un
la personne vous fait un sourire et ce
sourire là vous fait 20 jours dans ces
cas là c'est quand même pas mal
donc voilà ça évite le fossé puis ça
permet de tenir le coup
laurent je pense que le meg les mecs
vont lâcher du lest parce qu'ils n'ont
pas le choix et puis et puis il n'y a
pas non mais c'est ce que je pense c'est
ce que je pense vraiment je suis aux
premières loges
moi même je pense que les mecs vont
lâcher un peu de lest ce qui valait
détendre c'est qu'ils ne voient pas
leurs femmes militantes forcément ça
crispe un peu d'avoir à isabelle alonso
à la maison ça met un peu sa défensive
il faut que ça se passe dans la dans
l'escaut allait tourner au delà je
trouve extrêmement sympathique ainsi
qu'alonso c'était pour s'épousent pour
celle que le côté militant qui peut être
un peu castrateur parfois mais parfois
ratés et des jeunes intégrés l'homme
d'intégrer l'homme à la réflexion je les
fais dans la pratique même si ce n'est
pas le cas de toutes les notes qui n'est
pas toujours le cas de toutes les
féministes question difficile de
répondre à cette question je crois pas
en faire peur aux ngk l'inspecteur est
après le nord pour conclure alors je
crois que de pas perdre de vue la
nécessité qu on a les armes et autres
laissez pas passer bernard rappaz l'or
puisque je suis d'accord avec vous j'ai
heureusement ces phrases très belle
frappe c'est une suite ininterrompue de
gestion réussie quoi aller 81 quelque
chose même si on s'en fout ce parce
qu'un peu pervers doute mois mais la
perversité est un mythe inventé par les
bonnes gens pour expliquer l'étrange et
attraits de certains autres n'existent
pas la dernière c'était trop tôt dit
bon ben on dit choqué bernard avant tout
c'est trop tard pour conclure clémentine
que ce qui confère à la moi je pense
qu'il faut se méfier des préjugés et
puis voilà qu il reste on fait ce qu'on
peut et on essaie d'être libre heureux
et c'est mes hommes femmes femmes hommes
mais je pense que
effectivement depuis qu'il ya une lutte
pour l'égalité et que le statut d'homme
et de la femme est arrivée à peu près un
équilibre c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
la relation entre les hommes et les
femmes mais en même temps je pense que
c'est plus passionnant et plus excitant
et que si nous magazine de femmes on a
fait ce dossier ça nous a intéressés de
le faire c'est quand même dans cette
quête là c'est à dire que la quête de
l'amour la quête de la rencontre l'autre
et la dynamique de l'amour dont on
espère qu'elle est encore suffisante
pour nourrir nos énergies les gradins
dressés enseignants tous les cas merci à
tous merci d'aleri merci clément qui les
ont testés ici
[Musique]
m
tél
et maintenant je viens
[Applaudissements]
kouassi marie-reine le gougne
il
bonsoir patrick bruel énorme arrêt la
yann moix laurent baffie nicolas rey
donc vous marianne le gougne aux jeux
olympiques d'hiver en 2002 à salt lake
city
vous étiez juge et vous avez été accusé
d'avoir favorisé le couple russe au
détriment du couple canadien à la suite
d'un arrangement avec les russes c'est
un arrangement devait faire m'attendais
ne la jugez pas avant qu'elle ait parlé
quand même et ses arrangements ses
arrangements avec les russes devaient
permettre aux français de gagner par la
suite voilà ce qui vous a été reprochée
alors quelques mois plus tard vous étiez
suspendu de tout arbitrage pour trois
ans est suspendu aussi pour les jeux
d'hiver en 2006
aujourd'hui marie reine vous voulez
laver votre honneur et vous publié chez
ram c'est un livre qui s'appelle
glissade à salt lake city
[Musique]
vous n'êtes plus belle en vrac sur la
photo merci pour se confier moi j'aimais
5,2 à la photo et 5,8 en vrai
alors mariani la glace et vous c'est une
longue histoire mais j'avais rencontré
la glace pour la première fois à l'âge
de 5 ans et demi et vous êtes devenue
juge à l'âge de 20 ans signe très très
jeunes dont vous êtes très professionnel
vous êtes membre du comité national de
patinage artistique
et quand les jeux débute à salt lake
city en 2002 vous êtes en passe d'entrer
au comité technique
effectivement je commençais à devenir
une personnalité du patinage mondial et
c'est ça que le contexte était très
particulier le voit faire des jaloux
d'une certaine façon dans away le mot
est faible
oui d'autant que comme j'essayais
d'expliquer dans mon livre en fait j'ai
toujours été un élément perturbateur du
système commence avec en mémoire le
couple russe kirill qui s'est passé car
on écoute et j'étais correct avec vous
je parle pas bien
bien donc voilà donc je tout ça pour
dire vous êtes une vraie professionnels
de la profession
et quand vous arrivez salt lake city
pour les jeux olympiques
vous dites l'intrigué est omniprésente
annonce déjà une sale ambiance d'une
certaine façon
voilà - fa oui tout à fait en fait ça
faisait deux ans que
que l'on préparait le terrain pour le
couple canadien sur les pelles type près
savent et et de manière plus marquée
lors des championnats du monde qui se
sont déroulés l'année précédente à
vancouver donc au canada où le couple
canadien l'a remportée alors qu'en fait
le couple russe était meilleure et ça
n'a pas fait de scandale à ce moment là
donc les russes n'ont pas porté plainte
personne n'a rien dit mais au fur et à
mesure les mois se déroulant on sentait
bien cette pression manifestes de la
part des sommités du patinage mondial
c'est ça qui est très grave en fait
quand il qu'ils ont
l'année où les canadiens ont gagné alors
clair que les russes étaient meilleurs
oui pourquoi ils ont gagné un canadien
parce qu'effectivement il y avait déjà
un travail de lobbying
ben c'est une manière de vendre entre
guillemets en maths l'aide d'un raconte
d'ailleurs vous dit quand vous arrivez à
ce que l'ex city à une réception qui est
organisé par un juge canadien pour
l'anniversaire d'une juge paul honnête
c'est l'air chiant ce milieu je dois
faire encore les way d'ailleurs vous
avez vous avez été invité marie reine
dans un restaurant mexicain avait refusé
d'y aller
elle crée le droit à un nombre
d'invitations vraisemblable surtout dès
lors que l'on a su que j'allais jugé
pour la france
des couples quelques mois auparavant
j'ai alors en compte beaucoup d'amis
sérieusement est-ce que dans dans un
sport où l'appréciation artistique est
très importante est ce que le lobbying
mais pas inévitable une certaine façon
tout à fait je ne nie pas les faits
d'ailleurs moi aussi mais dans une
certaine mesure pour connaissez cas du
lobbying vous en parlait encore une fois
dans ce sport c'est à peu près naturel
puisqu'il est question d'appréciation
artistique
la vraie question c'est où commence la
magouille
parce qu'à des cadeaux qui s'échangeait
ce que on offre des femmes des voitures
de maisons des voyages comme lady a
plein de journalistes qui me posent la
question moi j'ai jamais trouvé lingots
d'or dans ma chambre d'hôtel en prend
ça comme j'ai expliqué je pense qu'on
perçoit ma personnalité aussi à travers
mon livre c'est que moi je ne suis
jamais rentré dans ce genre de schéma et
démarche
donc moi aucun juge officiel d'une
fédération ne s'est amusé à ce jeu là
maintenant je ne peux pas je ne peux pas
jurer de ce qui se passe autour de moi
je pense qu'effectivement il ya
certaines brebis galeuses mais de là à
jeter l'opprobre sur tout sur tout le
corps et râle ça je peux pas non plus
accepté en finir avec le lobbying c'est
quand même que quelqu'un comme sophie
moniotte qui a été vice champion du
monde 94 par l'amba oui votre patron de
l'époque didier gailhaguet et lui a dit
t'inquiète pas on va voir avec quel juge
on peut s'arranger
donc c'est bien là c'est quand même il
ya quelque chose est-ce que c'est du
lobbying est ce que c'est de la
magouille
j'en sais rien enfin si on peut
s'arranger avec les juges
non c'est vrai qu'on danse sur glace la
part de subjectivité est encore plus
importante
est ce que vous n'avez pas de sots les
critères quantifiables
ça m'a vraiment limité excusez-moi
mariale je vois comment il fait depuis
tout à l'heure
évidemment qu est ce que tu veux qu'ils
aient des problèmes avec les fables sous
pression la veille il n'y a pas de
problème entre les hommes et les femmes
n'at il rien de signé quant au réel je
vois comment je le vois fait aborder par
une extraordinaire jeunesse
le geste a été magnifique de sa part
j'ai voulu boire mon verre il était vide
ses vues inverse se poser la radio j'ai
lu ces jeux ce médian le regard que tu
lui as fait m'attend même moi qui suis
pure et héros j'ai craqué un petit peu
c'est me parler
la france y avait l'autre bout
j'aimerais bien savoir combien la juge
de lui donner s'il roule un patin
bon alors candeloro là c'est pas de la
danse assez du patinage candeloro a
déclaré les juges sont tous corrompus et
soumis aux ordres de didier didier c'est
toujours didier gailhaguet parole à
philippe vous sérieux on connaît très
bien la personnalité de philippe avant
vous insinuez quoiqu'il ait un peu bête
l'absolu m'emballe mais simplement que
je suppose que ces paroles ont dépassé
sa pensée sa pensée donc vouloir y règne
quand vous votez
les russes parce que vous votez pour les
ruchers pas pour les canadiens c'est ça
le problème c'est que tout le monde
s'attendait à ce que les canadiens
soient champions olympiques tout le
monde les voter pour les canadiens et
marie-reine qui est une espèce d'esprit
libre est arrivé là un politiquement
correct dix ans elle a voté pour les
russes elle les a peut-être trouvé mieux
bapt a fait ses besoins devaient voter
pour les moscovites board
mais voilà c'est parce qu'on s'attendait
à ce que je vote pour les canadiennes
sauf que c'est là que le bât blesse
sauf que vous avez déclarez vous l'avait
signé nous sommes soumis à des pressions
affreuse ma fédération
mon président didier gailhaguet je
devais donner dites vous je devais
donner la première place aux couples
russes j'ai jamais signé ça parce que
j'ai signée c'est que effectivement j'ai
craqué j'ai totalement craqué mais faut
comprendre le contexte dans lequel
j'évolue j'avais quand même dit je
devais donner la première à craquer
craqué alors ses commandes expliqué je
comprends que vous avez quand même
déclaré j'ai d'abord google
[Applaudissements]
marie-reine vous savez pas vous en
sortir sans sa petite taille à l'erreur
en revanche ces messieurs sur une
première moitié du jeu ces données
l'euro alors je devais donner dites vous
je devais donner la première place aux
couples russes
vous l'avez dit aux jeunes aux non non
absolument pas j'ai craqué effectivement
lors de la réunion de juges mais j'ai
craqué pourquoi parce que j'ai subi un
nombre de menaces invraisemblable
jusqu'à des menaces physiques et morales
dès lors que j'ai posé mon crayon
dès la fin de la compétition moi j'ai
fait mon choix parce que je considérais
que le russe était meilleure
je pose mon crayon je me prends une
première réflexion de la juge américaine
du jamais vu je me fais agresser
physiquement par un permanent de la
fédération internationale qui me bloque
qui n'empêche de sortir de l'estrade des
juges
je sors dans la patinoire dans les
couloirs je me fais agresser
physiquement par des inconnus à l'hôtel
lala la présidente du patinage mondial
m'agresse parce que je n'avais pas mis
le canadien premier alors là oui j'ai
totalement craqué et vous avez signé
vous faire soigner c'est ce que vous le
dites aujourd'hui c'est moi continue et
non le lendemain en réunion ii juge le
juge arbitre américain
toute démarche totalement inédite nous
lit une lettre ça c'est du jamais vu
et il accuse dans ces semaines les juges
qui ont placé le russe à la première
place d'avoir été malhonnête
oui j'ai craqué et en fait j'ai dit des
paroles qui me dépassait totalement et
qui n'était absolument pas la réalité au
lycée soeur j'ai signé ensuite vous
rétracter donc vous dites excessives
vous
marie-hélène on remet en cause ma
personne dans ce qu'elle a de plus
profond de plus sacré on a sali mon
honneur
ah oui tout à fait et on a complètement
sali mon honneur parce qu'on m'a traitée
de juges malhonnête et ça j'ai pu
commettre des erreurs mais je n'ai
jamais été malhonnête absolument jamais
que ensuite vous avez reconnus étaient
fausses oui tout à fait donc bon pour
injustes quand même assez grave selon
georges escande et je vous ai expliqué
j'étais dans un état émotionnel faisait
ce qu'on appelle l'état émotionnel
j'ai craint c'est l'état émotionnel
parce que vous en état émotionnel c'est
que ces pannes homicide ou c'est nos
missiles quand même je m'attendais mal à
nous on va quand même pas tout mélanger
madame c'est tout à l'heure j'ai tué
personne que je sache quand même alors
il faut aussi ramener les choses en vain
contesté comparer ses compagnes bien
alors sérieusement est-ce que tout ça
vous a pas est ce que tout ça vous a pas
bouleverser à ce point là on voit bien
ce quelque chose qui me tient à coeur
est ce que tout ça vous a pas
bouleverser à ce point là parce que
finalement vous êtes la fille d'un
officier de l'armée française et
finalement vous avez été élevé dans un
certain sens de l'honneur
c'est pour ça que ça a pris tant de
proportions non seulement ma famille ma
prime élevée dans dans le respect de
certaines valeurs dans une éthique dans
une morale dans le respect des autres et
surtout dans l' honnêteté vis-à-vis de
l'image que vous avez de votre père pour
vous c'est insupportable ça pas que non
par la famille ça et le nom de ma
famille a été traîné dans la boue et
c'est ses poumons table vous allez faire
quoi maintenant toute votre vie vous
avez ressasser cette histoire non
justement si j'ai écrit aussi ce livre
c'est parce que je veux tourner
définitivement la page de salt lake city
parce que pour moi ce sont des angoisses
sont des insomnies c'est quelque chose
de très dur à vivre au quotidien donc je
veux que les gens comprennent simplement
que la malhonnêteté en fait est la
réunion
et que et que bah moi j'ai jamais été
malhonnête donc je vais continuer
sérieusement marie-reine là maintenant
les yeux dans les yeux c'est bien quand
même que les russes ils ont fait une
faute oui le russe fait une petite
erreur mais j'explique d'ailleurs j'en
tiens compte puisque je mets 5 8 ans
premières notes alors que les canadiens
n'ont pas d'erreurs mais c'est plus
facile on sent pas retombée mais n'ont
fait aucun figure donc voila moi
spectaculaire mais voilà merci
est-ce que alors yann moix est ce que
vous pensez qu un débat là est ce qu'on
pensait que voilà qu'est ce que vous en
pensez maintenant de 7 à fait à ce que
vous croyez que que marie-reine le
gougne finalement bon est là elle a été
influencé pour voter pour les russes ont
au contraire elle est parfaitement
innocente et son honneur a été sa vie je
vais dire qu'elle est parfaitement
innocente mais en même temps je remarque
qu'à chaque fois plus d'explications
sont longues raies puis le sang c'est
compliqué ouais
à chaque fois que j'ai vu votre émission
en trois mots mais à l'arrivée nous
prouver qu'il est innocent là ça va pas
durer 4 minutes 30 ça dure et 27 minutes
32 et j'avoue que pour les asus ya du
louche
moi je pense que c'est bien ça va faire
le ménage dans le patin et je trouve ça
donc pas ta mondial je pense que là est
ce que moi ça me dérange pas la
malhonnêteté chez les gens donc bâche
comprendre
non mais ça va aller
c'est pas du tout marine
non c'est vrai du tout certain
aujourd'hui j'ai pas dire que c'est pas
du tout ce que je voulais dire je ne
demande qu'à vous croire etc je vous
crois et puis je m'en tape
mais sachez que même si vous avez été
malhonnête la tricherie et tout ça il ya
fait des très beau film est très beau
livre le mensonge
jusqu'où on peut aller trop loin à cause
d'un mensonge grâce à un mensonge
quotidien comme ça c'est très bien et
quand vous avez fait revivre à léonore
penser que maryland est coupable ou
innocente
j'y connais rien en patin je vais au
magnéto serge non mais les forces et les
centres et les rieurs date un énorme
effort de football maryland merci merci
patrick bruel bravo dans cette année les
mines
bravo marié à une pointe salut
[Musique]
j'accueille maintenant emma de caunes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je sais
avant de baisser à bon d'accord c'était
la solidarité féminine non vous
connaissez dites moi et m'a avoué vos
lentilles la ba oui parce que vous dites
des fois j'utilise ce handicap pour
moisson pour me protéger pour être dans
ma bulle
mais je joue sans mentir ouais mais
comme ça le public c'est l'impression
qu'il est toujours toujours joyeux
toujours content mais alors ça s'est
passé comment ce soir sur scène ouais ça
devait aller jusqu'au 30 mars et s'est
prolongée jusqu'à fin avril
merci non pas c'est génial alors c'est
sur la scène du petit marigny théâtre
robert hossein ça s'appelle la nuit du
thermomètre s'est écrit par diastème et
c'est avec frédéric andrau
[Applaudissements]
gfr le pitch c'est la nuit il fait chaud
vous appelez lucie faisait douze ans
vous dormez pas vous relever pour aller
boire un coup et vous découvrez votre
mère inanimée
qu'est ce que vous faites vous appeler
votre copain à la rescousse et là vous
passez la nuit comme deux enfants un peu
un peu amoureux un peu anar à refaire le
monde a parlé de la mort du sexe de la
vie voilà voilà
mais génèrent des marges c'est un
excellent félicitations alors on regarde
à quoi ça ressemble magnéto serge suis
la fille de son champion de perm
les trophées de rallye plein les
armoires deux cents l'heure dans les
dunes qu'il allait mon père 220
saloperies d'une pourrite plein de
callas pour it à peine deux ans et demi
qu'il est mort et voilà deux ans et demi
en septembre le doute s'était plaint
devant la cour il est mort et voilà la
fff comme tron et acheter un véhicule
fientes
j'ai mis du leur pour ça fignon comme ça
c'est pas bien de la peine à ma mère
francky moi j'aime beaucoup ma mère
terrorisée kiev
ça va filer des trucs mais si c'est pas
du tout ce que tu crois fait partie ce
papier tue pas dans un flot dangereux
tous les garçons se rend fou de moi je
les ferai ramper à mes pieds un par un
et toi tu resteras avec les énormes
blonde tout gratuitement bras les bois
il se sera pas la fête de t'excuser un
pas fait du tout jeter coûterait même
temps voilà mille personnages dans les
smartphones paiement dans une combe ce
soir
elle se débrouille très bien vraiment on
est très bien examen je trouve que j'ai
bien connu une actrice hors du commun et
si mon premier film podium marche
je m'engage faire un deuxième fils
michael c j'en rêve depuis des années je
trouve qu'ils vous diront que l'enclos
ces petits bouts jeune femme là qu'ils
arrivent à faire la nique à tous les
mannequins à l'extraordinaire merci
beaucoup c'était très émouvant région
c'est bien fait ça bah oui c'est
extraordinaire tout se passe bien
jusqu'ici
ceci étant je pense que enfants vous
deviez tracé assez grave non à ses fins
disons que j'ai justement pour pour
essayer de me battre contre ça je
faisais beaucoup rire mes copains
j'étais un peu pitre c'est à dire qu'au
début bondée au début de votre votre vie
tout allait bien
viviez avec vos parents votre père
antoine de caunes votre merguez royer et
vous étiez un petit peu comme les
enfants de jane birkin un bébé sac à dos
trimbalait un peu partout du palace à la
maternelle vous avez été 2 moiselle
d'honneur au mariage de vos parents pour
ça c'était c'était la bonne époque
c'était vos parents avaient 20 ans
c'était la fête tous les jours à la à la
maison éducation comme on dit un peu
rock'n'roll
à l'époque quand vous étiez enfant et
vous voyez votre père à la télé avec une
[ __ ] sur la tête en train d'être recul à
tort ça faisait quoi mais ça faisait
beaucoup rire mais ça faisait pas rire
tout le monde
c'était un peu compliqué à l'école parce
que justement il ya des profs qui ça
plaisait pas toujours et qui me faisait
payer ça c'était vachement difficile
parce qu'à la fois j'avais des copains
qui étaient fans donc c'est toujours
bizarre quand on à l'école qu'on aime
bien son père qu'on le voit pas des
masses parce que je voudrais pas avec
lui qu'avec vous oui oui on passait le
week-end ans en mai
j'avais tous mes copains super fan de
lui puis tous mes profs pas du tout
super fan
eh bien tant que j'ai un peu payé quand
même dans la scolarité de trois profs
font pas trop aimé les blagues ça c'est
la bonne époque une époque joyeuse et
pied après vos parents se séparent
malheureusement souvent
et là vous commencez à pas vous entendre
avec vos belles mères quoi vous est
vachement courant c'est vrai qu'en
france qu'on l'appuie dit dans sa vie le
dash mois en cours vous n'êtes pas
comment vous savez ça c'est assez
bluffant
non c'est vrai j'avais toujours eu des
problèmes avec vos belles mères pas
toujours mais c'était parfois pas facile
way
ces problèmes d'enfance vous emmène à
écrire des histoires écrire des poèmes
enfin à trouver un échappatoire la
création artistique wii passe ou petits
malheurs oui c'est ça c'est comme ça que
vous avez commencé en fait être
intéressé par la dimension artistique le
cinéma par la musique par oui parce que
j'avais un père qui trimballait un peu
dans les concerts moi j'ai vu j'ai vu un
concert de james bond à l'âge de 4 ans
je me souviendrai toute ma vie c'était
un truc un peu phénoménal j'ai vu de
plein de films j'ai eu la chance d'avoir
aussi des parents qui s'intéressait à ça
donc qui m'ont ouvert un peu c'est ça et
voilà ouais passionné très tôt par le
cinéma et puis vous faisiez là comme on
dit pour les six comme avec cette
journée de la femme moi je dirais le
pitre mais pour une fille en dit quoi la
baisse
le pitre le pitre ont dit quand même en
femme annoncé un peu une soirée
féministe clémentine autain l'api 13
févier l'abitre s sous le regard de
votre grand mère jacqueline joubert et
de sa grande copine odette lors donc là
vous avez commencé à allemand après
détruit de diction de respiration des
trucs un peu basique qu'il faut savoir
quand ton de la comédie mais voilà ouais
à 13 ans vous animez signer parade sur
canal j vous faites des spots de pub
donc le fameux crunch que tout le monde
connaît avec tout le monde adore ensuite
c'est un frère de sylvie verheyde vous
obtenez le césar du meilleur espoir
féminin enfin tout va bien un début de
carrière absolument extraordinaire et
puis vous dites ce césar a tout faux
c'est pourquoi annoncer
j'ai dit ça ya une polémique sur le
jugement de deux de ces armes
ils devaient être attribuées aux
canadiens ah oui c'est vrai maniant
passé dans les livres non sérieusement
vous visez de 10 quand vous avez deux
césar j'ai dit c'est facile quoi le
cinéma basser qu'on a quand on a vingt
piges et qu'on reçoit un césar on se dit
ouah c'est super le cinéma français
et puis c'est plus compliqué que ça et
puis en plus non je pense qu'en fait
c'est plus sain tout de pression qui
fait qu'il faut encore plus faire ses
preuves et je vous ai pas vus en fait
c'est que tous les six mois il y avait
une nouvelle star car c'est ça le truc
en même temps quand on regarde
l'histoire du cinéma ça a toujours
fonctionné comme ça on fabrique des
vedettes et puis il y en a qui marche un
qui marche pas alors ensuite fait
quelques bons films d'ailleurs restons
groupés les 1000 bornes l'astérix de
chabahar évidemment du nil moi j'ai
trouvé ça long du nil vachement bien
parce que c'est la première fois qu'on
voyait comme une vraie femme justement
et puis comme une petit oui c'est vrai
que moi j'avais un peu le côté étiquette
e pré ados qui collait à la peau c'est
un peu ennuyeux à la longue parce que
j'avais grandi et que même si j'ai cette
éternelle jeunesse en moi j'avais quand
même un peu envie de passer à autre
chose et les amants du nil c'est la
première fois qu'on me proposait surtout
un film d'époque où je pouvais jouer oui
autre chose le problème c'est que
j'avais sérieusement jamais fait encore
un très grand film
vous êtes d'accord mais voilà non
j'aurais janvier l'évêque oui mais non
et c'est compliqué parce que
c'est compliqué moi je sais qu'une fois
j'ai failli en ferrain et je ne citerai
pas pour mes couleurs
ouais j'ai fait des non j'ai fait le
casting d'amélie poulain avec jean
pierre jeunet et
voilà maintenant à un moment je me suis
demandé s'il avait pas une fatwa ou un
truc à dire qu'on m'a dit les trop
moderne pour que je suis moderne parce
que j'avais les cheveux courts alors si
avoir les cheveux courts c'est moderne
c'est que les metteurs en scène manque
un peu d'imagination corps et puis tout
à coup ma vie avec des rajouts j'avais
une des rajouts pour le film princess de
sylvie verra t on là mais non elle peut
tout à fait faire des films d'époque
alors c'est une histoire de cheveux
c'est un peu c'est un peu énervant
l'entente des trucs comme ça tant que
vous faites des trucs qui se plantent un
peu vous allez devenir culte après une
fois que vous serez morte il dit quoi
antoine de tout ça notre carrière de la
pièce là qui est un grand succès je
crois qu'il a beaucoup aimé la pièce et
il est plutôt il est plutôt confiant je
crois donc voilà très bien alors on va
faire une interview comme papa alors il
m'a deux co didier didier alors jen
[Musique]
division i featuring lundi stéphanie
alors est ce que comme papa ça vous a
aidé d'avoir un inconnu
oui et non c'est à dire que oui parce
qu'évidemment on ne recevait plus
facilement dans un casting que si je
m'étais appelé ma schmoll du mois mais
en même temps il fallait plus faire ses
preuves et mach molding ça met la
pression
ouais ouais est ce que comme papa on
vous parle souvent de votre père
forcément vous venez de le faire est ce
que comme papa vous en avez marre des
jeux de mots du j'en ai ma déconne moi
j'aime bien de caunes trois joints ont
des trucs plus un peu plus poussé est ce
que comme papa vous préférez les filles
et filles à quoi
non non non non j'ai fait j'aime
beaucoup les filles j'aime beaucoup les
films j'aime bien les gars
est ce que comme papa vous auriez jouer
dans un film aussi pourri que les deux
papa et la maman peut-être qui sait ce
qui est important c'est d'essayer
est ce que comme papa beaucoup avec les
gens s'intéressent encore un napoléon et
bah écoute et justement je pense qu'il
ya eu mistake
le truc c'est que les gens se sont
trompé en pensant que c'était napoléon
dont on parlait et je pense qu'on
parlait plus d'un un truc un peu l'upi
nesc pour utiliser ce terme que j'aime
bien c'est à dire un type un stratège un
grand stratège
après jules césar y avait lui après
napoléon pas napoléon peu importe
s'était d'abord avant tout un mec qui
qui pensait son sa vie un peu
différemment des autres
et puis qui le film qu'il en a fait
c'est avant tout un thriller un rom
enfin un très très beau film romanesque
et voilà est pas un film sur napoléon
mais il cartonne en anglais cartonnera
en angleterre je le promets est ce comme
papa vous êtes fier d'emma de caunes
ah bah non je peux pas être fier de moi
pourquoi bas parce que pour être fier de
soi il faut non moi je suis exigeante
avec moi même je me repose pas sur mes
lauriers comme on dit si ça colle
[Applaudissements]
m
et
et maintenant
[Musique]
et je
voici ce que kritter
[Musique]
scott ritter bonsoir vous avez 43 ans
vous êtes ancien officier de marine
les marines américains vous avez porté
l'uniforme pendant 12 ans et vous avez
combattu pour votre pays dans la guerre
du golfe sous les ordres du général
schwarzkopf voilà en 1991 vous rejoignez
les inspecteurs en désarmement chargé
par l'onu de détruire l'arsenal de
saddam hussein et vous faites ça je
compte 98 ou vous démissionner car vous
jugez que kofi annan et son représentant
sur place
prakash chats sont trop laxistes avec
l'irak que l'irak ne cause le conseil de
sécurité ne mettez pas en étant faible
interférence avec cruauté et surtout le
gouvernement se dit le film américain
allait en fait à l'encontre de l'équipe
des inspecteurs en lui demandant
d'espionner saddam hussein à ceux ci
n'allait pas j'ai démissionné pas cette
raison alors aujourd'hui vos positions
prennent d'autant plus d'importance et
de et de reliefs je dirais que après
avoir été marines après avoir été
inspecteurs de l'onu en irak
vous êtes contre la guerre en irak vous
expliquer pourquoi
dans un livre est publié au serpent à
plumes et qui s'appelle guerre à l'irak
ce que l'équipe de bush ne dit pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors pour vous ce que tu return
évidemment aucune raison de faire la
guerre à l'irak puisque l'irak dit vous
et désarmez vous dites qu entre 91 et 98
tout le potentiel scientifique et
technique a été détruit et qu'il était
impossible pour les irakiens de
reconstruire finalement des des missiles
des gaz etc
en fait ce que j'ai dit plus précisément
c'est que 90 à 95% des capacités
irakienne et notamment toute la capitale
nous savons où aller où il est passé
mais enfin ce n'est pas à moi de dire
que l'irak complètement propre c'est
quand même à l'équipe d'inspecteurs de
le dire et au conseil de sécurité
il reste sur les 80 sur les 100 % il
reste encore 5 % dont on ne sait pas
encore où ils sont et on est de toute
façon ce n'est pas une excuse pour aller
faire la guerre parce que quelle arme
l'irak at-elle produit certes on ne peut
pas savoir où les armes sont pas non
plus prouvé que l'irak détient ces armes
donc n'est pas de justification pour
faire la guerre voilà donc pas de
justification pour les armes irakiennes
dont vous savez qu'elles ont été
détruites à 95 % puisque vous étiez pas
de justification non plus pour le
pétrole contrairement à ce qui a
beaucoup étaient racontées ici au là
puisque vous dites qu'en fait l'irak ne
refuse pas de vendre son pétrole aux
américains d'irak ne refuse pas de
vendre son pétrole à qui que ce soit ré
cds que ce n'est pas son souci on ne
peut pas faire la guerre pour des
histoires de pétrole pour savoir si le
dictateur irakien est bon ou mauvais on
fait la guerre à l'irak cinégard si
l'irak nous attaquent ou signal commun
constitue une menace ainsi que le
définit le conseil de sécurité des
nations unies mais jusqu'à présent ces
conditions nous sera réunie je ne suis
pas contre la guerre en soi gérer deux
ans la guerre
quand marine et je me défendrai mon pays
s'il le fallait mais je ne vais pas
faire la guerre pour faire la guerre ou
mener une guerre d'agression illégale
contre l'irak parce que là c'est ce que
fait les états unis en ce moment alors
c'est pas les armes
c'est pas le pétrole on pourrait dire
c'est les liens qui a entre eux soit
disant saddam hussein et et ben laden
vous dites je tape sur tout le monde le
sait saddam hussein est un dictateur
laïque il a aucun lien avec al-qaïda et
gagnent deux chenaux là encore nous
n'avons pas pu démontrer avec quelques
gaiden 2 je ne dis pas ce que l'irak
n'est pas d'armes description
maintenance des routes massif c'est à
nous de trouver
je ne dis pas qu'il n'y ait pas de
gillot si quelqu'un plein de démontrer
ce lien d'accord mais ce que je
n'accepte pas c'est l'idée d'aller faire
la guerre sur la base de rumeurs et de
spéculations ont fait la guerre lorsque
l'on a des preuves incontestables d'une
menace actuellement on ne peut pas
démontrer cette menace les monnaies
risquées armes de destruction massive ou
les halles organise son pari ce ne sont
pas des intentions plus d'islamistes à
londres par exemple tout l'irak
c est donc en fait il ya eu une guerre à
zéro mort mais certains ont blanchi une
guerre à 0 cause grecque les causes les
raisons nous paraissent complètement
absurde estime absolument donc c'est pas
les armes c'est pas le pétrole s'est
passé pas les liens entre oussama ben
laden alors et saddam hussein alors on
pourrait penser que c'est pour apporter
la démocratie à l'irak et c'est un des
points les plus intéressants de votre
pipe à ce que vous dites que ça c'est
très intéressant
vous dites sur la porte des démocraties
à l'irak si les irakiens peuvent voter
comme dans les pays démocratiques
d'occident ça marchera pas parce qu'à
60% de chiites en irak
et qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire ils vont
élire un gouvernement chiite qui va
s'associer directement avec les chiites
iraniens et donc l'irak devait devenir
comme l'iran c'est à dire un pays
fondamentalistes intégristes musulmans
que là on serait peut-être un peu naïf
de croire les etats-unis lorsqu'ils
on veut créer la démocratie en irak il
n'a pas du tout l'intention de
simplement dès le g7 a mûri hussein en
mettant à sa place un autre dictateur
qui pourrait maîtriser alors je ne dis
pas que la démocratie soit impossible en
irak a admis ce serait peut-être pas mal
à noter mais on ne peut pas imposer la
démocratie il faut qu'elle vienne de
l'intérieur
il n'y a aucune façon mal pour
démocrates pour imposer on pourra en
tout cas promouvoir la démocratie dans
ce que vous dites en fait c'est que bush
s'apprête à violer la loi internationale
pour rien alors évidemment il ya
toujours des partisans de la défense
préventive qui disent par exemple si on
avait attaqué hitler ça aurait évité de
évidemment tous les massacres tous les
génocides qui a eu pendant la deuxième
guerre mondiale sont d'aller attaquer
avant sauf que c'est exactement
l'argument qu'à utiliser hitler pour
attaquer la pologne
donc si on rentre dans ce genre de
raisonnement d' attaque préventive
il vient d'en sortir à jamais le
totalitarisme aujourd'hui il est
peut-être aussi américains feront les
américains ont peut-être inventé ce
concept complètement inédit de dictature
soft rien dictature qui n'est pas qu'ils
n'utilisent pas les méthodes
dictatoriales classique c'est-à-dire
d'abrutissement des masses par la
violence mais plutôt les bondissements
des masses par par le divertissement par
exemple donc un espèce de totalitarisme
insidieux extrêmement sauf exportable à
l'infini parce qu'ils passent par le
divertissement la joie la consommation
et le produit et que peut-être que là
c'est impérialisme dictatorial me soft
est plaisant les dictatures plaisante en
fait et peut-être que le vrai le veut le
vrai danger c'est bush et non pas sa vie
saine qui lui finalement est cohérent
avec une certaine culture qui n'est pas
ay par son peuple
autant que bush mais parce que bush les
américains ne l'ont jamais élu laurent
est ce qu'elle lui la paix une image de
antipatriotique alors qu'il avait servi
et 12 en son pays
comment c'est perçu le fait de deux
patries d'yquem est de faire un constat
logique du manque d'arguments pour faire
cette guerre commencée perçu dans votre
pays lorsque je me suis engagé dans les
marines et j'ai pris le serment de
défendre la constitution
week-end contre ses ennemis intérieurs
extérieurs je n'ai pas ce prix ou le
serment de défendre le président le
vice-président le pentagone la maison
blanche le pentagone
j'ai fais serment de défendre ce bout de
papier qu'il défend représente les
valeurs lesquels est fondé notre société
alors ce que j c'est que nous le peuple
américain se nomme une démocratie qui
doit fonctionner pour ce faire il faut
que le peuple participe à ces
démocraties sokone citoyens soit engagée
une fois passé tout est simple le
consommateur mais prend soin des acteurs
des participants actifs à la démocratie
et pour ce faire ils doivent prendre
l'information doivent avoir cette
responsabilité est évidemment le pire
danger ces deux réduire au silence ceux
qui s'opposent à la politique du
gouvernement en les qualifiant de dancy
patriotique en fait la chose à saucats
rien que l'on puisse faire c'est
justement d'ouvrir les terreurs lever la
main et de mettre au défi les élus de
défendre leur politique s'ils ne sont
plus responsables à l'asmo règne à plus
de démocratie est actuellement aux états
unis justement nous perdons le droit de
nous appeler démocratie c'est ce nous
permettra aux éleveurs aux éléments du
11-septembre de détruire en fait la
démocratie américaine
de la même façon que les nazis en
brûlant le reichstag ont détruit la
démocratie allemand
[Applaudissements]
ça fait plaisir ça fait plaisir parce
que ces temps ci les américains on les a
un peu déçu quand même la wii en
septembre n'est pas un chèque en blanc
est un passe droit à une scène primitive
nouvelle pour pour toutes les guerres à
venir
le problème dans ce que vous racontez
quand même scott ritter c'est
qu'aujourd'hui la guerre est inévitable
quoique raconte hans blix la guerre est
inévitable parce que george bush ne peut
plus faire marche arrière sans perdre la
face c'est à dire ce qui est terrible
c'est qu'il va être le seul à faire
cette guerre simplement pour pas perdre
la face
cela s'est vraiment c'est vraiment là la
véritable onde de toutes les tragédies
criminel parce que si george bush avait
réellement servi son armée au lieu de la
déserté pour aller au texas
eh bien il serait que la guerre consiste
à tuer des gens des hommes qui tuent
d'autres hommes et donc cette idée
d'aller faire la guerre pour sauver la
face sur le plan politique devrait être
abominable pour n'importe qui qui
connaît la game
or george bush ne connaît par la guerre
la plus que le vice président chez nice
paul wolff vite ne connaît pas la guerre
pas plus que donald ron foule tous ces
gens qui sont nés va-t-en-guerre
justement ne connaissent rien à la
guerre s'il connaissait quoi que ce soit
la guerre est bien au contraire ils
chercheraient tous les moyens pour
justement éviter la guerre plutôt que de
se lancer dedans à pieds joints
cependant une situation qui va tuer des
milliers d'américains et peut-être des
centaines de milliers d'irakiens alors
évidemment nous ne parlons pas des
victimes irakiennes parce que ce sont
des noirs pas les salles est bon alors
vu leur valeur n'a pas leur vie n'a pas
autant de valeur que la nôtre mais il y
aura des centaines de villes d'irak du
rac 1 qui est qui qui vont perdre leurs
seins c'est un génocide
alors évidemment maintenant on risque
l'ouverture de ce que vous appelez la
boîte de pandore c'est à dire que si
l'armée américaine progressent jusqu'à
bagdad
si ça va vite ça ira mais si ça prend du
temps on risque pendant cette
progression du coc veille jusqu'à bagdad
on risque l'explosion du monde arabe
parce que le monde arabe ne va pas
rester
évidemment inerte face à ces combats
s'il se prolonge et pire que ça si
l'armée américaine finit par arriver à
bagdad
elle aura du mal parce que quoi cent
cinquante mille hommes à soumettre une
zone urbaine qui est habitée par 5
millions de gens c'est très compliqué
quand on est 150000 pour soumettre cinq
millions de gens ce qui risque de se
passer c'est ce que vous dites c'est que
les américains soient piégées à bagdad
que les boys soient piégés et que pour
les sortir de là pour les américains
envoient la bombe atomique
c'est précisément l'un des risques en
effet ce que j'ai appris la longtemps
s'est hissé de prendre george bush au
pied de la lettre ils à 10 quand il a et
quand est arrivée aux affaires qu'il
délogerait saddam hussein
il est en train de tenir sa promesse sa
promesse son conseil de sécurité a dû
que si les américains sont coincés sont
piégés dans un pays hostile et son on
risque de être exposés à des armes
biologiques ou chimiques sais pas si
c'est le cas pour les rythmes enfin on
suppose donc si notre revue se trouve
coincé là bas tout savoir qu'on a envoyé
six cent mille personnes pour libérer le
koweït là on est on envoie quelques
trois cent mille soldats pour attaquer
une ville qui compte cinq millions
d'habitants il ya toutes les chances
pour que les américains n'arrivent pas
juste qu'un bond à des six se trouvent
effectivement piégé là bas alors selon
la doctrine militaire de boucher bien
nous aurions le droit d'envoyer à ti tre
donc préventif la bombe atomique ce qui
serait un cauchemar
l'ambiance ouais non mais vous dites
george bush est un fondamentaliste
chrétien qui dispose de la plus
puissante armée du monde voilà la
réalité
vous craignez ben laden vous craignez
saddam hussein mais aujourd'hui ni l'un
ni l'autre n'ont la plus puissante armée
du monde à leur disposition ce n'est pas
seulement ce que moi je crains il
faudrait que le monde entier craignent
cela aux états unis nous disons qu'il
faut
affrontez l'intégrisme musulman
représentée par al qaïda et les ben
laden qui sont la plus grande menace ou
le monde mais ça n'est pas le cas la
véritable menace c'est effectivement
l'intégrisme chrétien chrétien qui a
pris le contrôle de la maison blanche et
qui a la main sur le bouton atomique et
qui se sert de la puissance militaire la
plus puissante du monde de manière
illégale
c'est là la première menace au monde ben
laden n'est pas l'ennemi public numéro
un c'est george w bush c'est c'est plein
de choses honteuses de dire ça en tant
qu'américain mais c'est vrai george bush
comme un fondamentaliste chrétien est ce
que vous ne pensez pas que c'est le pape
qui aulas est vraiment livre ça ton
ultime bataille contre cette guerre qui
compte éventuellement se rendre à l'onu
qui peut changer quelque chose
c'est à dire qu'il faut quand même
comprendre que le fondamentalisme
chrétien qui a été repris par georgia
beaulieu bouche rejette le catholicisme
le pape la chrétienté train traditionnel
c'est-à-dire que si vous n'avez pas
adopter le christ en tant que sauveur et
bien voulait pas créer un autre à ses
yeux le pape n'est pas chrétiens les
catholiques ne sont pas chrétiens la
plupart des chrétiens ne le sont pas et
les fondamentalistes dans l'eure dans
leur idée du chrétien du christianisme
se moquent éperdument du reste c'est à
dire que josh
avec son cercle d'amis on a incarné un
ben laden a représenté le mal aux états
unis pendant des mois et des mois et que
d'un coup il ya un glissement on a
changé d'incarnation du mal pour glisser
insidieusement vers saddam hussein
pourquoi on a changé d'ennemis qui
voulait comment ça c'est fait ce passage
du groupe
tout d'abord il faut quand même remonter
avant le 11-septembre pour répandre que
le gouvernement bush avait déjà ma mise
ou en tout cas des visées sur saddam
hussein ou et et la reprise l'irak
n'avait aucune façon pour engager
l'opinion publique ou le conseil de
sécurité autour de cette cause est alors
le 11 septembre est arrivé comme une
espèce de pain béni
on avait su tout d'un coup transformé
ces attaques du 11 septembre pour
mobiliser le public américain autour de
cette idée de c'est de lutter contre le
terrorisme
ça m'amène à dents mais le 12 septembre
lendemain donc des attaques roma elle
les épaules wolf habitants ont dit au
président pour gagner la guerre contre
le terrorisme et bien il faut éliminer
saddam hussein et mener la guerre contre
l'irak alors que nous apporte al qaïda
et ben laden c'est une excuse pour aller
attaquer saddam hussein
[Musique]
voici gomez du bois ta femme là
messieurs
[Musique]
gomez
- 2 un bon soir en soi c'est le marché
va bien se passer léonard
on va prendre ce nouveau volet non ça va
pas te fasses et toi gomez c'est qui
gomez et du bois voilà alors je suis
très très très heureux de vous recevoir
parce que votre cd donc produit par te
fare et chantée par vous c'est
formidable voilà flickr la loi c'est un
des meilleurs trucs que j'ai entendue
depuis longtemps vraiment et je vais
raconter un petit peu votre histoire
tout a commencé en 2001 par gomez et
tavarès attention ensuit qui était tirée
d'une compilation intitulée mission
suicide
initié par le même te fare et le morceau
c'était les rimes
g
[Musique]
donc ça c'était gomez et tavarez qu'est
ce qui s'est passé le réalisateur gilles
paquet brenner a racheté les droits du
titre et s'en est inspiré pour écrire
une comédie une comédie qui va sortir le
7 mai 2003 sur les écrans avec stomy
bugzy dans le rôle de gomez et titoff
dans le rôle de tavares plus jean yanne
et noémie lenoir voilà et bien un disque
aujourd'hui qui sort qui s'appelle gomes
et du bois parce que tavares je crois
qu'il est parti en partie en colombie
ouais il est parti en colombie lors de
l'import export
ah oui c'est ça il est dans la neige
carbonique c'est ça oui où on sait ce
qu'on des entreprises
voilà donc ta mère et c'est parti
maintenant c'est gomez c'est du bois et
on va écouter votre dix mois je trouve
c'est une véritable comédie musicale je
suis fan je le dis tout de suite
j'adore première chanson didier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc ça c'est la chanson de présentation
gomes et du bois et après il ya le jour
de paye des condés didier le soleil
vient de se lever
yann lheureux qui font tomber il va
falloir encore craché pour ces deux cons
ils viennent toujours au mauvais moment
le jaune tapis c'est énervant gommer et
du bois veulent croquer
c'est l'instinct condé voilà donc à une
chanson aussi que j'adore qui s'appelle
marcel murat c'est l'histoire d'un assez
franc 1 c'est l'histoire d'un gaulois
oui qui écrit à gomes et du bois didier
[Musique]
marçais
salut marcel ici dos mais ce que m je
répond à ta mère en justice où on fait
du théâtre d'échangés à la bourse un
moyen de tourner j'ai ensuite les
paupiettes dégueulasse tomic est après
cet appel de pain pita ses preuves
comptables ou air s'en tenant aux
ministres allemands et la troisième
les secours une série noire pour tf1 le
type de leur seul sacre à pékin 22 lits
matin la blache ont toujours rêvé
d'avoir un fils donc il est tout le
monde le club de cannes à venise man
hulk l'attaquant palais sébastopol
désignés comme les chiottes si jamais
vous
jean marie et moi voilà et puis alors un
moment il y en a un qui tombe amoureux
d'une [ __ ] roumaine qui s'appelle
causait didier
[Musique]
non non
non
[Musique]
ça y est tu retour au cheval avec tout
l'espoir à la con ça fait deux semaines
que vous m devait perdre la raison
ta star n'est qu'une goutte de lait 100
pap larry king a fait des allers retours
se trouve à celle que l'on appelle
article 16 de roumaines connect now
she's n'est qu'un parfait de la plus
tard chacun son tour au comiccon ce
stade elle est une voie sera centrale
amour leur côté ont décidé hier son beau
centre voilà que z featuring rona
hartner et puis alors ya le sud via le
tube oh quel commissariat qui est une
reprise de california pictures in china
didier
tél
[Musique]
tous les connaître notons encore que ça
hollande au exige le clip un magnéto
serge
[Musique]
tous les connaître
toujours tu seras ya toute chose sur
laquelle les trois si tu veux voir la
vraie vie n'a rien su
n'hésites pas fait dix-huit issa de
mango mais zoo du bois
gomez et l'ivoire la meilleure
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi j'ai rien à dire je suis scotché par
se glisse une écoute en boucle tout ça
génial je voulais faire profiter tous
les invités les spectateurs de se disent
que je leur conseille d'acheter ces
grands voilà c'est tout ce que j'ai à
dire vous n'avez rien d'autre à dire
vous toute façon si juste un truc
ouais je t'écoute de femmes c'est les
embrasser les eagles qui sont inspirés
n'ont as a way ah ouais tout le monde
croit que a
on a sorti un peu plus tard parce qu'on
a essayé la ligue 1
[Musique]
oui
alors on va passer à l'anti portrait
chinois a autorisé le principe le
portrait chinois c'est si vous étiez une
fleur lentilles portrait chine est assez
si vous étiez un [ __ ] qui seriez vous
moi je du bois ouais gomez
si vous étiez une infirmité
l'impuissance
pas mûres si vous étiez une drogue douce
si vous étiez un super pouvoir lire dans
les pensées pour les interrogatoires ça
peut servir
le viagra si vous étiez une guerre
guerre des nerfs si vous étiez une femme
femme à poigne
margaret thatcher si vous étiez une
façon de mourir la pente disons parce
qu'après ça fait possible si vous étiez
une insulte îlotiers si vous étiez une
arme un flash ball
si vous étiez une perversion sexuelle
moi si vous étiez une opération
chirurgicale la guerre en irak
ce que vous étiez de mauvaise nouvelle
coupable si vous étiez un film raté
voilà le gendarme et jean ne remettent
pas mieux si vous étiez un mauvais
rappeur
eh ben florange si vous étiez un très
mauvais rappeur faf larage si vous étiez
à pêcher l'avarice la convoitise et toi
te fare la gourmandise
il a tout
[Musique]
sordo
t
[Musique]
merci vous restez avec nous pour le
blind test on va passer au blind thèse
ce soit blind test spécial journée de la
femme est aux platines j'appelle moi
j'avais les provoquer des années 80
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
monsieur
le ca
[Applaudissements]
et en plus je vois si max mesdames
messieurs
c'est
reste la gaude eléonore valat suis fan
aussi ils sont extraordinaires 1 les
lyonnais ont concédé il est trop fort
non ah ouais mais recevoir bientôt en
extradant ouais c'est extraordinaire
attention didier wampas mountain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui les erreurs de casting ces damnés de
la pouf la job
alors attention vous connaissez la règle
du jeu je veux l'interprète on joue par
équipe
donc l équipe de les honneurs vin est là
contre l'équipe d'emma de caunes et à
partir des banques aux six chacun pour
sa gueule mesdames messieurs didier
l'interprète
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
ça fait un point pour l'équipe de
norbert et là attention philippe
[Musique]
je galère bon match
[Applaudissements]
je vous
au cdh
paradis
ouais ouais
un poireau l'équipe d'emma de caunes de
points pour l'équipe de léonore varela
attention je veux l'interprète philippe
m
mais
[Applaudissements]
il traîne avec la juge qu'elle y aille
traîne avec la juge attend avec le
gougne bon attention
[Musique]
moi sourit je n'ai rien d'autre à dire
et nous l'a dit
mal deux heures serge privé
oui
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
attention
fox un beau
[Applaudissements]
attention attention continue philippe
applique
[Musique]
temps forts
je n'écris pas entre les uns contre les
autres c'est débile
oui soyons soirs après chacun pourra
profiter
attention attention vous y êtes philippe
un container
attention si vite
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
tu peur de deux jambes ou deux yeux
c'est toute une journée
qui
george où claire denamur
mais comment bravo muriel fait quoi dans
la vie n'ont rien fait rien
j'en cherchais j'en avais trouvé bien
pas de problème vous l'avez reconnu en
forme ce dont les murs bravo attention
attention physique
[Musique]
non pas que l'intervalle
souris qui est premier
biolay le salaire si bas
ça c'est vachement dur reconnaître
reconnaît antoine duquesne honnêtement
c'est super dur
attention attention vie parce qu est ce
qui me prend la journée et la venue
aujourd'hui
oui
je suis là
attention vip
savannah l'aca compte pas les jeunes
le point en face oui déjà
mais in communes save et gambien ça fait
6 pour l'équipe d'emma de caunes et 4
pour les kids le narval
attention attention dit
[Musique]
pour la droite c'est quoi
n
bon on l'a vu dans la bataille quitte
donc c'est l'équipe d'emma de caunes qui
gagne pas cette fois
elle a même plus de quatre mois
bon ça c'était une mise en forme chantez
maintenant c'est chacun pour sa langue
on passe vraiment au banco au super
banco au mega man quoi l'ultra moncaut
attention fille
[Musique]
petit bébé
attention attention
[Musique]
c'est bien je suis désolé je suis désolé
c'est ma fille ben rien ma fille le bon
coup attention mesdames messieurs nous
passons maintenant au super banco ah oui
philippe
[Musique]
puis d'antoine bello en même temps bon
ouais il est fier de toile en toile
arrivée tient ce soir là bas attention
attention le mega man coup c'est pas
facile philippe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quoi
dix morts donné au match
et voilà maintenant très facile ultra
bon comme ça je vous en fais cadeau fip
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je crois que les grands gagnants de la
soirée ça se joue entre entre max et
entre max et laurent baffie
tu sais qui est une pochette des sceaux
nous ils sont habillés comme toi
attention attention c'était tout le
monde en parle
l'émission qui résiste aux programmes
sur la lune et sur l'a6
l'épreuve roland dumas tard
michel à fond blanc des vi nations
patrick
[Musique]
sur les musées
avec 3 c'est
jusqu'à cb
original en trouver un
trois pattes
[Musique]
c'est philippe torreton il le remplace
voilà les honore
le tallec
avec les honneurs varela
et joli ciel banda
les eaux de la sierra madre toranian du
showman elle qui sort lundi avec les
états généraux de la ville ont-ils
autant les droits des femmes c'est bien
la question
non
white podiums chez grasset
si les autres best-sellers nicholas ray
allen moniteur votre horaire
c'est mon cerveau
lombardia marie-reine le gougne
[Musique]
ce que c'est
absolument emma je compte à numéro vert
[Applaudissements]
au théâtre marigny
amélie rossi stoner
la très sexy
pas c'est
foncia pas me voilà comminges et du mois
ouais
[Applaudissements]
c'est génial génial isabelle plus quand
la loi est le single s'appelle hôtel
commissariat
la série reporters sans frontières
l'album s'appelle dit
jean louis murat à logis j'allais me
voilà c'était souvent tard on
sa mémoire
je vais
[Musique]
le
je l'aimé
[Musique]
et
je n'ai
je l'aimais
onfray
[Musique]